وقت الاطلاق انا شخصيا ما توقعت السخم على
الموقع بهذا القدر فالناس متحمسين كثير
على الموقع يعني زي التطبيق فعلا اكثر من
ما توقعت بمراحم يعني مو طبيعي يعني اول
يوم تر طح السيرفر والعجيب ان الصاله
استهلاكها عالي مره اكثر من ما تصورنا ما
تخلون صاله عامه الكل فور يو قصدك يعني ز
لك ترى في اشياء انت تبغاها فور يو تويتر
سواها بعد 13 سنه اي لا لالا اطني
اسبوع هذا اللي قاعد يقوللك عليه كل
شوي يقوللك لا لاقول زر يا رجال حط زر
فيديو تحط فيديو بكاست تحط زر و بلاي ايش
فيك خمس دقائق خمس
دقائق اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد
الرحمن ابو مالح هذه الحلقه مع صديقين
عاصروا بدايات تحول ثمانيه الجديد حلقه عن
موقع ثانيه وراديو 8 وبناء الفريق التقني
بس لم تقتصر على المنتجات التقنيه فتكلم
عن اليه العمل في الشركات التقنيه سلطان
مثلا مع العمل عن قرب وعلي مع العمل عن
بعد كيف تعمل المؤسسات بين هذين النظامين
ش الاليات الم مفترض تسويها لتضمن نجاح
ايهما مواضيع ثانيه مثل هل تصمم وتبني
تطبيق على لغات هجينه ومتى يكون قرارك انك
تبنيها على لغه النظام الام ساريف حلوه
ممتعه مفيده وهي كذلك تحمل اراء مختلفه
يعني الاكيد في واحد مع والاخر ضد فودي
اسمع ارائكم حيالها كذلك الحلقه مع علي بو
صالح الرئيس التنفيذي للتقنيه في ثمانيه
وسلطان خيال المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه
دراهم قبل ان نبدا اود شكر رعاه هذه
الحلقه شركه صفا ومنص سله اما الان لنبدا
لما ادخل تطبيق انا واحد عندي مرض اوكي
اني لازم ادخل اسوي التحديث لازم الان
الان لازم اسوي التحديث فاي تطبيق يعني
حتى لو ابل ارسل نفس الليله تلقاني ممكن
وانا قاعد واضيع وقتي ان بس اسوي التحديث
تنتظر مت السياره جا تحديث صباء
الفجر جلست كذا خمس دقائق بس عشان احمل
التحديث و قاللي انست بياخذ 50 دقيقه الان
خذ فانا احب احدد بس فتخيل هذا الهوس ان
لما ادخل على متجر التطبيقات اضغط تحديث
اسوي ريفريش يطلعلي ك 26 تطبيق يبغ تحديث
روح اضغط بنفسي بعضهم تلقاه قبل فما احس
ان يتحدث بسرعه يعني ابل عندهم ر اصلا حتى
التطبيق لما تنزل تحديث الجديد ترى ما هو
انستنت يطلع عند كل احد رولين فخلال اول
ساعات بعدين يبدا يطلع للناس اذا اللي
واحد حريص ويروح يبغى يسو اي بس لنفرض انك
مفعل التحديثات
التلقائيه كم ياخذ يوم الى ان ابل
تحدث احس انهم ما يحدثون الى ان ينزل في
الستور نزل في الستور صار عندك نزل على كل
الناس هل ابل تحدثه في الخلفيه ما اعرف
والله اي يتحدث في الخلفيه يتحدث الخف
اكيد لاني احيان بخش مثلا اي تطبيق تلاقيه
عليه علامه الساعه هذه حقتهم فتصير انا ل
لي سنه سنتين ما اذكر اني اروح واحدث
بنفسي دائما القى تحديث جديده موجوده عندي
الحالات الاكسبشن
اعرف انه في تحديث جديد نزل واسمع عنه
فاروح اشوف اذا نزل ولا احدثه بنفسي لا
هذه تخوفني ان الناس ما تحدث بس اذا انت
تحس ان 80 بناء على ارقام عندكم 80% 8%
مشغلين خلينا نشوف الحين في الاب ستور خشه
خصوصا ايوس الاندرويد غير غير تماما
الاندرويد قصه اخرى يعني بس والله ترى ترى
عجيب اللي جاس يصير في ثمانيه ترى قصه
مختلفه تماما
ها قصه عجيبه الاندرويد بق عكس الهذا ولا
ايش ان تطبيق اندرويد افضل من الايفون
جوده
ولاخ لما يقوللك التحيز على ترى يعني يعني
مادي يشتغلون على اندرويد يعطيهم العافيه
فعلا فعلا فعلا رائع رائع رائع والله عجيب
تشوف الاثنين انا اتوقع ابو صالح هو
المتحيز
يعني الحين يا اخوي لا لا اتذكر قبل كم
يوم اني ماخذ الايفون الاندرويد ايو
واوريه مطورين الايوس قول شفت هذا هو
زيه اوكي جميل في كم صفحه فعلا في اليو اي
راح اجمل في اندرويد في شي اسطوري كود بوش
اسمه ايه بدون ما احد يحدث التطبيق انت
تنزل هات فيكس ك هذ انستنت على طول تصير
شي اسطوري يا رجل الايوس لسه يعني ابل
وريفيو يلعبون عليك يقولون 15% ديسكاونت
اذا الريفن حقك اقل من مليون لنا سنتين
مقدمين وما ا عجيب شكلهم
يعني حركات يا اخي والله دي اتش اتش المره
المليون قام عليهم على سفه كالندر زعلان
لان غير منطق الليسو ترا فعلا فعلا يعني
انهم يجون يقولون تطبيقك ما يسوي شي ش
يعني ما يسوي شي رافضينه يعني لا لا وترى
يعني على حسب على حسب يستقون احيانا
احيانا في الريجستريشن بروسس يقولون لا
ليش تسال ميل ولا في ميل مالك دخل اي
حرفيا حرفيا ممكن كذا يقول لا تسال طيب
خلاص وشله انه ما هل هي نس سريع عشان تكمل
لا ما هي نس طب خلاص بس انا لازم اقول
فكره عشان ما يزعلون يحدفون
التطبيق فجا تروح سسبند تنزل انت منافس
مباشر الان
انتب ممتاز ان شاء الله يعني اقوللك ان
الخطه حقتنا ترى سويت ولا ما سويت لا فيجن
برو الله يهديكم سويت سويت والله بعد
تقرير الاسبوعي
بو لا مو
بطبيعي كم س كان 1700 دولار ما ادري لا
تذكرني صراحه 2000 دولار شي شي ريال غير
انك اذا اشتريت ظهر الصندوق غير انك
اشتريت ابل كير بلس اب كير بلس طلع اذا
بتشتريه 799 دولار وا لا يشمل العدسات لا
القزاز القزاز تشتر الحاله ب 230 دولار
ضمان رجل يا رجل بس من زمان ما تحمست على
منتج زي ك لا حس مره بس ان قلت في كم حاجه
تخوف اوكي الحين انا جس ابغ اطلع
ايش انه
هل ابل
بتسوي انه منع بناء على الموقع الجغرافي
حقك الدوله اللي انت فيها فهل ان يجي
السعوديه بد ما يشتغل لانه بس الان مسموح
بس في امريكا وكندا ابل هذا اللي يخوفني
يعني اشتري 13000 ريال شي يمكن ما يشتغل
هنا رغم ان حركاتهم حركاتهم بس تغير ريجون
وذت ما في ولا حاجه ثانيه الشيء الوحيد
اللي يستقدم فيه البيمنت مثد بس اللهم اذا
بس ان ممكن ليش لانه فيها حساسات كثيره
مستشعرات كثيره فيمكن انه ما اخذ موافقات
امنيه يعني فيقولون تدري بنوقف احنا مادخل
احنا نتكلم عن امريكا وكندا تشتريها كيف
سايبر تراك اللي تتوقع بحجبها ولا لا هذه
اللي فيها اشياء
نظارات وعدسات وكاميرات بس السيارات اقع
وضع مختلف يعني في مليون شي يمر عليه عشان
يدخلون السعوديه اصلا ما اتوقع بدخل
بسهوله يعني اساسا لا يسمع منك يعني وك
تجيبونها يجيبونها بس صعب تشكل والله ما
تحمست على سياره في حياتي منكثر ماحست
سيبرك يا اخي
اسطوريه
اسطوريه اول واحد ت اسمع يقولك لا لا ايش
دعو في كم واحد والله انا اول مره يقولون
سياره الاحلام عجيب تجمع لك كل شيء جيب في
سياره شكلها رهيب في سياره سريعه في سياره
يوتيل تيران اوكي يعني كلش تبيها حتى
تاخذها كامبن في مكان بتسوي ما بسويها
يعني لكن برضه حلو الاوبشن انه يكون موجود
ف تحمس صراحه لا لا يعني انت ما عجبتك
السياره انا اشوف عاديه صراحه يعني مهما
اشتهر م بعاديه ا انها سيئه ا انها حلوه
ما في عاديه عاديه الصدق يعني هيعد عن
العاده
تما كل شي الا ان عادي ما فيها شيء مميز
صراحه يعني مهما شفت عليها ريفيوز وكذا ما
احس في شيء مميز يعني شكلها اما انك
تكرهها او انك تحبها لا شكلها رهيب انا
احب الاشيا النديه انا بعطيك شيء هذا اللي
اكثر شي انا صراحه متحمس اجربه الستيرنج
ويل لما تلفها ما تلف 360 درجه كيف تلف
180 وتوقف اوكي بناء على سرعتك وبناء على
انك موقف ولا مهدي خلاص تبغى تلف اقصى لفه
بس ك عجيب يعني ما هو ب قتلا هذ حالها
يعني هم ما خلوه
مربوط ميكانيكيا خلوه بال يعني مبرمج فهمت
فلو طاف السياره وتسوي زي كذا ترى ما
بتحرك الكفرات اوكي فهمت بس هو على حسب فت
طبعا هي غالها تعلم اتوقع اي حس بالضبط
هذا هو كنت بقول يعني مختلف هذ حالها يا
اخي الريوس يخليك يعني عادي ما تشيل همه
زي تقعد تف خ تر اللي يعجبني في تسله يعني
بعد التجربه هذه
انها فيها اشياء بسيطه بس انها رائعه
اشياء بسيطه يعني مثلا اول ما تشخ السياره
انها تعرف اذا انت بتمشي سيده ولا ريوس
فتشتغل على طول يما تختار ريوس او سيده
ماق جابت فيك العيد الا
[ضحك]
الله لا لا القياده الذاتيه
خربوطي خربوط لا لا في تحديين مفترض ان
اذا تبغى اتوقع السياره تشتغل في مدينه
حاجه واحده حده يحتاجونها انه
الامانات يعني يسوون الشوارع انهم ما
يتفلسفون وشخص ما يتفلسفون يعني مفترض
انهم يسوون الاشياء اللي معترف ومعتمد في
كل مكان في العالم الخط مثلا هنا في بعض
الخطوط تلقى شكلها حلو اللي لما تكون
ويمكن مكلفه اكثر حتى عشان يكون الشارع به
الطريقه فتلقى الخطوط اللي
على اللي تكون غير متصله والخط الاصفر
اللي الكتف الشارع احيانا بويه واحيانا
تكون نقاط عيون قط عرفته لما تكون ينقط
تخربط الشاشه الاله ما تفهم هي هو هو
الرسمه كذا ولا لا ما يعني احيانا تلخبط
بس ما تكون بويه ولا غلطه خلاص تعرف انه
هذا كذا هذا كذا هذا كذا هذا كذا على طول
احيانا الارصفه تكون بطريقه حلوه جماليه
بس انها تكون طالعه كذا فهي تلخبط تقول ما
ادري هو رصيف ولا شش ما تعرفه فتاخذ يعني
تعط بس اذا مشت الاشياء تمام
تمام لكن مره قبل كم يوم ماشي ما شغلت
ذكاء يعني ما خليت القياده ذاتيه ما شغلت
بس اني كنت
ماشي هي تصير ذكيه احيانا فيش تسوي طبعا
في كاميرا قدام هنا في السياره فهي تقرا
اللي في السياره ل المساعده في القياده
الذاتيه وفي غيرها فاذا انا على جوالي اذا
طلعت جوالي وانا اسوق بتقول يعني بتدري
اني ماني مركز في الطريق فتجلس تقول ط ط
وزي
كذا كنت ماشي فتقدر تاخذ قرار اذا انت
مشغل ذكاء سناعي بس انها بناء على فهمها
اتخذت قرار غبي والله ما ادري وقفت
السياره في نص الطريق ك توقف وانا ما ابغى
اوقف انا ادعس لانه كان زحمه شفت طريق هذا
شارع الم مستشفى
المملكه حوس عبد العزيز مع ثمامه مع تخصصي
60 مليون شارع في بعض المهم انه ازدحم ففي
ناس هنا وفي ناس هنا وفي ناس هنا و ناس
هنا في ناس هنا فانا بسك المهم وقفت وقفت
و ماشي من يعني هذا الكيجن ديتكشن لو كان
يبغى يوقف ما ادري خ ما بكمل قسما بالله
كان سبب حادث الاول اللي وراي يوقف يعني
الحمد لله صراحه عاد لو صار حاد اصلحها
مشكله ثانيه هذا تحدي هذا موضوع كم لها
معك الحين كيف تجربتك معها سوفار انا احس
ان احبها احب اوكي جربت قيادتها ثقيله يا
اخي ثقيله مره على حسب تغير دركسون تقدر
تختار تقدر تخليه اخف اي تقدر تختار من
بلاد ولا سبورت ولا عادي بس هذه بسرعه ولا
لا لا لا ل على
الدراكسون فلا لا انت على حسب الخصائص
اللي انت تبغاها له خليه
عا يعني لا حلو والله انا احس انها سيارت
فهني اوكي يعني احب استخدم اشياء في
البدايات والمعاناه يعني مره جت ان خلصت
الشحن ورحت اوقفها نسيت يعني فتتبع ف
التوريط هذه حق ايرلي ادابتر لحظه خلص ش
سويت رجعت البيت اشحنها اه بس قعد ساعات
سياره توقف عليك لا لا يعني ما بيق 10% اه
اوكي
ف فكنت كذا متوتر اني يعني ما اقدر اشحنها
في
مكانج كم تقعد معك تقريبا الشحنه الوحده
يومين يومين ا يومين بس يعني هي هم كاتبين
630 كيلو بس لا يعني يمكن في المدينه وعلى
حسب اختيارك النوع هوا وما هوا دعستك وما
دعستك دعستك اذا هي تاخذها السرعه يعني
سريعه ولا لا بس سريعه بشكل جنوني موضوع
اخر هذا يعني امي ما تركب معي ط
الله يعط بس حلوه يعني ما عاد
اوصلها بس بس يعني هذه انا في شغله انتوا
اثنين يعني طبعا علي هو الحين رئيس تنفيذ
التقنيه في
8 اللي عرفني فيه سلطان سلطان عرف قديم بس
انت اثنين شلون تعرفون بعض يعني زملاء في
البترول يعني انت اثنين نفس الدفه نفس
الدفه ف نفس كل شي درسنا سوا يعني يعني
تقريبا ولا كم اكثر من 30 كلاس درسنا سوا
يعني كثير كثير مره يعني ومشروع التخرج
سوا كثير سوا ك مؤسسين شركه مؤسسين شركه
سوا يعني اسسته انت في الجامع على اخر ت
اخر ترم تقريبا كان مشروع تخرج يعني ولا
ا المشروع التخرج صار يعني تحول الى انه
يكون
شركه شباب اشتغلنا اكتشفنا انه في كذا
منتجات رائعه تطلع فقلنا خلنا نسوي شي طيب
وين ناكل كان لكم علاقه فيه ولا يعني كان
في الدفعه بس ونفس الكلاس لا اتوقع مو نفس
الكلاس صح كان داتا بيسبيس مختلف لكن هو
بالاخير علي كانوا شغالين على شيء هو
واسامه وانا وغازي وعمر كنا شغالين على
حاجه وبعدين قلنا اسمع ليش ما ناخذ
المنتجين هذه وندمج ونسوي شركه انا كنت
شغال على هو كوين ناكل احنا كنا شغالين
على شي اسمه واكي زمان مره 2012 كلام هذا
ملاعب نظام حجز ملعب كره قدم اسمه ايش
واكي اسمه ايش يعني واكي واكي يعني شيء
جيد واكي يعني يعتمد عليه كلمه حجازيه
اتوقع والله
اي واكي اول مره اسمع هه طيب ش صار على
التطبيق يعني احس الناس تحجز ملاعب اي
يعني وقتها يعني كان في 12 13 الناس اصلا
تطبيقات يعني كنا مره مسجين ذاك الوقت
يعني اصلا ما كان في كريم وهنجر ستيشن
وقتها يعني ما كان في تطبيقاتك الوقت كنا
سابقين وقتنا مره كثير يعني وين تقنع
اصحاب لاعب
انهمل معير الناس شلون يدفعون يعني كان
الوضع كان الجامعه صح قنع الجامعه الجامع
وقتها ش الدفع ما في مدى وقتها ما في مد ط
كل فيز ماستر كارد حت تقنع الملاعب حتى
انهم ياخذون مدفوعات يعني كان وضع حوسه
مره اص
السو اقناع الجام وقتها الجامعه اخذه كان
بدون فلوس ولا شي حطينا في الجامعه وبس
يعني حاولنا نبيع حولنا اذكر جبنا ارب خمس
ملاعب لكن ما يعني ما كان ما كان احسن شيء
في الحياه بس وقفنا بعدين اوكي وناك يعني
حس الى الان ترى مشروع ممتاز بس يعني تذكر
انه طلع يعني فيتشرد مميز في الاب ستور صح
اي اكثر مره كان في حمله رمضان وهذا اللي
يعني وناكل كان فكره فكره اتوقع يعني من
الجامعه انه كنا دائما نطلع ويلا نتهاوش
بال ساعات ها وين نروح لا هنا لا هنا
واللي يعطيك اكترا والي ما يعطيك ا اوكي
بواحده من اهدافي اني بسوي تطبيق يجاوب
السؤال هذا بضغطه زر يعني فتحول الى
كونه مشروع واحده من المواد بعدين تحمسنا
وسوينا تطبيق في الصيف من الاصف
وبعدين اطلقنا ولعل انتشر اكثر مما يعني
كنا فجاه لا اذكر جت حاضنه اعمال قاعد
تقول لنا تعالوا تعالوا تعالوا كنا احنا
وقتها في الشرقيه في البترول يعني تعالوا
الرياض نبغى نحت ظنكم يا جماعه ما نبي
بزنس يعني هذا بس كذا فن بروجكت ق تعالوا
ف فبس رحنا الرياض وبدينا مع حضيه الاعمال
هذه وتطور الموضوع من اخي حلو المشاريع
هذه اللي تبدا كذا فكره يعني اذكر حتى
طموح بعد ت واكي كان كذا يعني كان فكره
نسوي تطبيق يخدم يخدم طلاب القدار
التحصيلي عندنا كان واحد مجمع اسئله وكذا
قلنا خلفب بدات فكره يعني ما كان نوين
بزنس اساسا يعني فجاه كبرت ووصلنا كم 8
الف مستخدم
يعني ح الافكار الصغيره هذه اللي تكبر
تصير مره حلوه متاكد يعني بس عندي سؤال
مره رائع بعد شوينا
بودكاست جرب حركه
جديده باخذ الك وارجع
بس حلو الحركه
صراحه من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم
ورفاهيه الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول
سكنيه مبتكره ومستدام مع شركه صفا
المزيد في وصف
[موسيقى]
الحلقه عشر دقائق من صباحك كفيله باطلاع
على ما يهمك ويعني من احداث
العالم الفجر اخباري وننشر منه حلقه فجر
كل يوم نتكلم فيها عن جديد العالم من
احداث واخبار ونشرحها ضمن سياقها من تاريخ
لتطورها كل يوم بيومه كل خبر بوقت ب كاست
الفجر متوفر على جميع منصات البودكاست
اشترك وتابع
[موسيقى]
الجديد عندي سؤال ثمانيه ليش بحرف هندي مو
بالرسم الهندي مو
بالرسم اوفي في الهذا لا لا يعني هو
الفكره انه
يقول حتى اللغه الارقام الهنديه هي تعتبر
ارقام عربيه يعني ارقام معربه فهمت لان
احنا نستخدمها ما اقتنعت صراحه يعني هذا
خلاص هذ اعرف انه صراحه الشكل الهندسي
العربي الرهيب اللي بالزوايا وخلاص ما
اذكر حتى في ثمانيه معتمد كولسي رحتوا
لفيتوا لفه وحطيتو حطينا الثمانيه وترى سؤ
عبد الرحمن كثير عن السؤال هذا اوكي ممتاز
بس ترى منطق لانها طبعا انا
ضد
اوكي
لكن يعني احس انك دائما لما تحاول انك
تخالف الناس باستعمالهم غالبا تفشل زي لما
كنا نستخدم الكاف الفارس ما تضبط يعني
طولت بس ما اضبط في كل مكان ما هي مستخدمه
وثمانيه اللي هي هذه الهنديه اللي قنا
هنديه مستخدم في كل مكان يعني في الطرقات
مستخدم كرقم عربي
في في القران مكتوبه بهذا الشكل فهي في كل
مكان فان تبغى تقول الا استخدم حقتي فهمت
فحس
انها احس مادري صادق مع انه انا انا ما
ادري يعني انا انا كنت متنبئ انه كل خلاص
الدوله بتمشي توجه انه تعتمد الارقام
العربيه الهندسيه هذ اي فانا توقعت انه
خلاص يعني كل احد قاعد حتى انا عندي الحين
في الكيبورد في الكمبيوتر محط انه الارقام
لا تحط لي الارقام حط
لي تدري ايش التعارض ان احنا داخليا باقي
واتوقع حتى في منشوراتنا وكل شي باقي
نستخدم الثمانيه اللي نقول انها ما هي
اللي هي عربيه اساسا قصك اي اللي هي حق
الزوايا تشوف تغريداتنا تشوف تدوينات
فاحس ان في تعاره ب انك تعتمد هذا الشعار
الثمانيه وبعدين قاعد تكتب الثمانيه دي بس
هذه رمزيه وهذه لغه احس شويه مختلفه ولا
اي بس يظل انه ما في اتساق واحس دائما
الاتساق افضل من عدم الاتساق قصك فاهم
قصدك فهم قصدك بس ترى قضيه الارقام يعني
يعني متعودين حتى احنا بقرا يعني حتى كبار
السن ماعرفوا انجليزي تلاقيهم يعرفون
الارقام انجليزيه طبيعي بالنسبه لهم ما
يتعبون عليها فحس متعودين القام انجليزيه
ايضا او الارقام العربيه الاصل يعني ما هي
قضيه ان احنا مختلفين في هذا اوكي الكاف
الكاف الفارسيه اتفق 100% هذا كان جديده
وهذه ما حد قاعد ي لكن الارقام متعودين
عليها ت كل مكان موجوده
اهعا
دخل بس هو صراحه شكل ال هذه جامد يعني لكن
حس انها قابله لانها تفسر خيمه ان
خ تتكلم ناس يقوللك عند القلم راس القلم
ارجوكم تفسير واحد رقم ثمان اي بس كان
سؤال سلطان انه ليه يعني هذا الرقم
الهندي لا لا بس ليه ك ليه اللفه يا ابو
انت سالت ولا انا سال اسئت الجوديه
هذه لا احنا احنا نقول ان في رقمين حلو في
العربي الهندي فيه العربي العربي الاصيل ف
1 تو 3 اللي هي وا ا
الرسم الرسم هذا الهندسي هو عربي اصيل
واحنا نفضل ان نستخدمه سهل جدا ممتاز ما
يلخبط كثير يعني اشياء ارقامنا العربيه
مفترض ان نستخدمها تلقاها موجوده في كل
برامج العالم ان العالم كله يعترف ان
ارقام عربيه تلقاها في ادوبي ولا في
مايكروسوفت يكتبلك اربك ديجت فالناس تعرف
انها ارقام عربيه ليست انجليزيه الا احنا
نسميه انجليزيه بس الثانيه فهي عربيه
الثانيه ترى هنديه عربيه يعني العرب طوروا
فيها ليست كما هي فهي برضه عربيه لكنها
احنا ما نستخدمها ماكن نفضلها
بس
يعني يعني تفضيل شكلها جميل ترى تفضيل بس
ان هنا يعني مثلا بالنسبه لي احس ان لما
نستخدم الارقام العربيه الاصيله فواحد
انها هي ارقام احنا ابتكرنا واحد ومنطقيه
وجمالها الهندسه يا اخي لحالها ك واثنين
اذا اتخيل على النطاق العام مثلا في
الشوارع انك بدال ما تحتاج انك تكتب 100
اللي هي سرعه الطريق 100 بالعربي الهندي
ووم بالعربي خلاص اختصر خلاص اختصر خليها
بالعربي الكل العالم يعرف هذا الرقم وهي
ارقامك فانت ما تخليت عن هويتك بالعكس انت
جالس شيء انت تخليت عنه فتره ترجع بس تقول
هذا حقنا انا هذا اللي توي كنت اقوله انا
توقعت احنا متجهين له الاتجاه انه خلاص
بنعتمد العربي العربي فحنا ما بنغير
ارقامنا في كتاباتنا وفي التحرير وفي كل
شيء نستخدم الارقام العربيه لا تنسال اما
الشعار ف
كان اسهل انه نستخدم عربي هندي كانت حلوه
يعني ما لان ما ادري ايقونه فكان تحدي كيف
نقدر نوصل الى ان نقدر نصنع ايقونه حلوه
مفهومه اول ما تشوفها بتعرف ونقدر نختصرها
فاذا تشوف الايقونه هذه على طول بتقول
ثمانيه فيوم جت جا الاقتراح هذا كان على
طول يعني انتهى يعني واضح ان حل
المشكله في نقاش كان في تحدي انه كيف
نخليه ولا لا نخليه ولا لا نخليه ولا لا
بس انه انتهى النقاش بانه يبقى ليش لانه
خلاص اقدر اكتب قبلها راديو واحطك شعار
فقط تعرف ان راديو ثمانيه اي مكان تشوف
الشعار انت بتقوله اي احد يعرف ثمانيه ولا
ما يعرفها بيقول ثمانيه ما بيقول شي ثاني
كان خيار ذكي
جدا ويستل ستاند باي تعل قولتهم طيب يلا
غيرت لا لا خلاص
خلاص لا تخليه اتفلت على دراهم ايش في
دراهم كيس مبسوط وهذا كيس ولا هو فقاعات
ولا يعني لا
تخليني اشياء اسوا اصلا الناس يقولون عن
هذا لكن الحمد لله حفظ عن القول للحين
دراهم كيس جميل كيس فلوس والله مبسوط وهذا
بالعكس بس انا اسئله الوجوديه واللي ما
لها جواب و تخصص اص قاعد يقول لي خيمه وما
خيمه
هذ داما ما احد يفسر الا
انت
احسن احس احت جا منديل تسلم تسلم تسلم ايش
كنا نقول كنا نقول انهم طلعت من الجامعه
سويت مدري شلون بعدين رحت
اشتغلت انت في سابك صحيح وبالتوازي طبعا
كنت شغال مع الشباب في الشركه في اقواس ما
اشتغلت مكاني انا في من الجامعه على طول
لا على اقواس على
اقواس ف سبك صح بعدين استيسي بعدين استيسي
اوك بعدين ثمان بعدين ثمانيه تمام فحين
ودي
اعرف كيف العمل ما بين الشركات الكبيره
والشركات الصغيره جيد ا طب انا انضميت
سابك تقريبا
2016 طبعا كنت اول ما
انضميت
مطور يعني الفريق فريق التطوير كن اشتغل
فيه كان 38 شخص تقريبا قس من تقنيه
المعلومات 4000
شخص 4000 شخص تقريبا الشركه كلها كان شخص
شخص او يعني شركه جدا ضخمه قسم تقنيه
المعلومات الحاله على 4000 شخص يعني انا
جزء من جزء من يعني عشان اوصل رئيس الشركه
يمكن تسعه تسعه مدراء عشان اوصل تقريبا
ف يعني شركات كبيره بطيئه بطبيعه الحال
لانها كبيره فالمشروع اللي بتتوقع ان ياخذ
برا شهر شهرين بياخذ عندهم سنه بين
موافقات وتصميم و وتحليل وما الى ذلك لين
توصل لمرحله الاطلاق يعني فهي بطئ بطبيعه
الحال كبيره
ضخمه الايجابيات اللي فيها واللي تعجبني
لازالت يعني في ناس كثير اللي يشترون
شركات صغيره يمقتون الشركات الكبيره عشان
اوه يا اخي هذول متخلفين ولا هذول دائما
ما يستخدموا ناحيه التقنيات دائما بطيئين
انا بالنسبه لي كون المنظومه فيها اليه
وتعمل بنجاح اشوف هذا جدا شيء كبير يعني
يعجبني ذا الشيء فتشوف مثلا في الشركه
في عش اقسام كلها تشتغل بالتوازي وكلها
تطلع منتج واحد سويا تبدا تقدره يا اخي
بعدين لانه في في البدايه صادق في النظره
الساذجه هذه انه لا الشركات الكبيره عقيمه
وفل بروسس وبطيئه ونفس الشيء بس توقع كل
ما تنضج شوي فكريا تبدا تفكر كيف انه يا
اخي ما شاء الله تبارك الله كذا اله كبيره
شغاله مع ناس لو واحد راح لو خمسه راحوا
ما تفرق لان يعني شي شي غير طبيعي فاتفق
معك واحس هذا التحدي يعني في ثمانيه اليوم
قاعد نكبر والفريق قاعد يكبر قاعد نعاني
من نفس المشاكل اللي في الشركات ال كبيره
اوردي حلتها قبل فتشوف يعني احد طلع احد
جاء لا تزال الماكينه زي ما سلطان شغاله
وقاعد تجون نفس الجوده ما اختلف عليهم شي
فحس هذا موجود شركات كبيره مستحيل تلاقات
صيره شك صغيره واحد استقال اثنين استقالوا
لو راح مس الشركه كل شي حرفيا
يخرب طبعا اتوقع هذا الطبيعي انت تبدا في
البدايه تلاقي على جرتهم الحمض حقك والساس
والفالو والشي اللي بتبيعه والشي اللي
بتضبط ولازم لها السرعه وال فليكسبلتي هذه
ل ما توصل خلاص مرحله انا لقيت الفورملا
الصحيحه كيف انا جها واخلي لها بروسس صحيح
بالضبط وتتعلم الاشياء اللي يسوونها
بروفيشنال يعني اكثر اللي هي كيف ترسل
ايميل كيف تعامل مع مديرك كيف تعامل مع
قسم اخر كيف تكسبهم كيف يعني اللي هي
المهارات الناعمه اكثر تعلمها يعني بعكس
مثلا كون شركه صغيره بتتعلم تعلم كشي
بنفسك كل امور تقني بنفسك بتشتغل ماليه
بتشتغل مواد بشريه بتشتغل وش يعني خدمات
حكوميه علاقات عامه تسويق بين في الشركه
كبيره بتسوي شي واحد يعني كانك نمله على
قولتهم فانت بتسوي فقط مهمتكم ولا شي غير
مهمتك الله يرفع
قدرك النمله النمله بالعكس شي جيد يعني شي
جيد شي
ايجابي بالعكس انها تسوي شغلها بنجاح
شغلها اللي تشيل الاغراض وتمشي بشكل جدا
ممتاز فنفس الشيش كانت كبيره يعني ف
وبيكون عندك وضوح تام لمهامك في الشركات
كبيره اتوقع صح فعلا يمكن انت كموظف انت
ذكرت مثال انك بتسوي كل شي اذا كنت المؤسس
او شي زي كذا بس اذا كنت موظف شركه ناشئ
يعني يحصل ان في الغموض عدم وضوح المهام
تغيرها بسرعه تدخل ممكن على انك مترجم تنت
بانك مارد بشريه يعني عادي صحيح تصير كثير
هذه هي اذكر بدايات في الاقواس يعني
اشتغلت اشتغلت مبرمج ومدير مشاريع ومورد
بشريه وماليه كلها في نفس الوقت انشغال
يعني فيعني جرب هناك في الليل كنت اشتغل
كل شي في اشتغل بس يا واحد يعني حرفيا
مضوع مختلفه يعني طريقه التفكير مختلفه
تماما وحتى يعني فهذا كل ينطبق على كل
الشركات اشتغلت فيها يعني تقريبا نفس
الشيء يعني اغلب الشركات كبيره نقول سابك
كانت نفس طبيعه العمل اوكي الحين برجع انت
قالتك الثمان لان حس انها مهمه لانها كانت
في تاريخ مفصلي في
حياتك والله يوم جاني يعني معقوله في احد
يسوي زي ك يقوله مالك كل شي حاط انا في
اكسل
شيت
بس انا اتذكر اني انا يعني اللي عرفني
عليك سلطان كنت اقول له ان نحتاج احد يمسك
المشروع تك بس انا قد شرحت لك الفكره اول
شيء انا اتذكر ان قد حاولنا نسوي شيء بدين
ما
بطلنا بدين انا قلت ترى ما اذكر اول مره
شرحت لك فكره التحول ثمانيه الى شركه
تقنيه تتذكر يعني انا شوف ما في احس جلسه
واحده يعني انا فهم من ناحيتي اني فهمت
الفكره كامله انا حس انها عده جلسات ليه
ما بادي انه اوكي الشباب متوجهين هذاك
الاتجاه لانه جزء مني صراحه كان يفكر من
البدايه انه انتم محتوى محتوى محتوى تركيز
محتوى تركيز محتوى وانت كنت دائما تقول لا
تقنيه ثمانيه شركه تقنيه يقول اوكي بس
الحين تراها شركه محتوى يعني ما هي شركه
تقنيه لكن اذكر من البدايه اول جلسه يوم
جلسنا اذكر في واحده من المقاهي كنت تقول
لي انه تحتاج احد تقني يكون موجود ومادري
شو قلت لي انه احنا بننتقل اتوقع حتى قبل
صفقه العربيه او يمكن كانت صارت المجموعه
السعوديه
و قلت لي انه ابغى ثمانيه تصير تقنيه
بالكامل واله ما اتوقع المعالم كانت واضحه
الى وقتها يعني لكن بعدها ك قعدنا نجتمع
اكثر من مره لين ما شوي شوي بدا التوجه
يعني خليني اقول يتحدد اكثر يتحدد اكثر
وانا احس الى الان الى الان مادري اذا
توافقون الراي ولا لا هي بالاخير تجربه
يعني تجربه وبتعد وبتظبط وبهذا لكن يعني
الشيء اللطيف انه يعني الاصرار على هالشيء
يعني انه احنا تقنيه تقنيه تقنيه وتقنيه
هي اللي بتمشينا في المستقبل واتفق معاه
يعني 100% ويعني انت هو اتخذ قرارات يعني
هو ساعدنا في البدايه يعني شكرا لك والله
اهلا وسهلا حياك الله ما سويت شي ترى اسكت
بس بس الكفايه انك جبت علي يعني هذه
عا صعب عاد والله كان اقناعه يا اخي جلسات
تذكر جلسات ومكالمات ول و شايف نفسه شايف
نفسي اخكر جاب الشنطه
وكذا بالعكس والله اني كنت يعنيان ويا اخي
تنصحني ولا ما
تنصحني يا اخي الواحد يسال نفسه برض يعني
قرارات مصيريه لا لا
بس بس يعني انت انت اللي خليت انه نستخدم
سويفت صح في البدايه يعني انه تكون نيتيف
نيتيف انا متعصب بشكل عام لل نيتيف لانجز
اللي هي الاصليه حق كل بلاتفورم عشان تقدر
تستفيد بكل ما البلاتفورم هذا يعطيك ا
وخصوصا ان عندنا مشغل و تستخدم ادوات
اساسيه في الجهاز عكس مثلا تطبيقات ثانيه
اللي ممكن ما يستخدم موارد الجهاز نفسها
بس تستخدم المشغل الصوت المدري ايش فاذا
كان يمكن ما هو نيتيف وسويفت مثلا هنا في
حاله ايو اس ممكن يهلك البطاريه 100% 100%
واشياء اوريدي يعني على قولك انتجريشن مع
السيستم يطلع لك بره اذا صار بلاتفورم
جديد تلاقيه اوريدي مدعوم لانك استخدمت
نفس المحرك هذا والبطاريه السرعه يعني
كلها كلها شي صراحه انا دائما مع النيتف
مهما حاولت في الهايبرد او التطبيقات
الهجينه ما بتوصل لمرحله النيتف الا لو
حطيت ضعف الوقت اللي بت في نيتف فيعني كنت
اشوف فتره في تويتر ناس كل نفس الموضوع
هذا كان رياكت نيتف وفلتر ان خلاص ما
بنستخدم نيتيف يعني
ابدا اشوف الاشياء اللي يسوونها تحتاج وقت
كبير ان توصلها يعني عن تجربه سابقه يعني
صعب جدا النف ضعف الجهد عشان توصل لمرحله
الص ريح
بالكس من الشركات اللي
حولت
ما ما اشوف
خاطئ على حسب التطبيق فرق يعني بعد ما حول
كان تجرب
حش فجيت
بيرمنت خل نشرحلك الحين دقيقه انت لما
تيجي تعطيه شي يقدر ريليت طيب ج ج حلو حلو
حل حل حلو لا لا خل ي جربني
ايك كنم ك كنم في المجموعه المجموعه
المنظومه الكبيره طيب لا شوف شوف الان اذا
جيت تبرمج بلغه معينه لكل منصه في لغه
يعني معينه فمثلا ايو اس بشكل عام كل
الماك بشكل عام والاي او اس لها لغه سوفت
الاندرويد مثلا له لغه جافا مثلا
الميكروسوفت لهم لغه استشار فهذه اللغه
مبنيه لبرمجه التطبيقات على هذه المنصه
تمام الان في لغات تب فيها مره واحده تبنك
تطبيقات كل هذ المنصات مره واحده جيد فهي
تتحول اللغه تتحول التطبيق الى اكثر من
تطبيق نس الوقت فدائما استخدمت هذا الشي
بما انه في تحويل لتطبيق من شكل لشكل اخر
دائما يكون النتيجه ماه افضل شي حطها يعني
لو اسويلها على جتهم تصور هي ليرز طبقات
فعندك النظام الكور مبني عليه يسمونه فريم
وورك ويبرز تنتهي بلغه البرمجه لغه
البرمجه عادي ممكن الشركه نفسها يكون
عندها لغتين برمجه او ثلاثه زي جوجل عندها
اكثر من لغه ابل عندها سويفت وعندها
اوبجكتف سي ف النيتف هي ترجمه فوقها
احيانا تكون ترجمه انه لغه واحده فيصير
اول ما اكتب فيها بتحولي هنا وبتحول لي
هنا فما يكون التحويل 100% ولا احيانا
تكون صفحه ويب تماما بس متهي كه على انها
تطبيق يعني وكثير كثير تطبيقات تستخدم هذا
الشيء هي صفحه ويب ترى ما هي بالتطبيق لكن
شغاله داخل التطبيق اتوقع كان فتره كبيره
بنك لهل تنقى كثير من كل بنوك كل بنوك
كانوا يعني ما كان تطبيق مبني على لغه
الجهاز نفسه فهو مجرد صفحه حولت حول حولت
تطبيق ومو بخطا ترى في ناس يحسون ان خطا
بس مو بخطا ترى اذا انت عندك يعني مصممين
جيدين مبرمجين جيدين هم بخطا فلما
تستخدم
لغه النظام نفسه اللي هي دعمته يسهل عليك
انهم هم اوريدي سووا مكتبات وسووا ادوات
كثيره انت تقدر تستدعيها
بضغط يعني سطر فتجيبها فخلاص تستفيد من كل
اللي هم سوك باسهل طريقه بينما لما تروح
انت تستخدم ادواه ثانيه ممكن انت تروح
تبني من جديد ف مشغل ابل مسويه مشغل جاهز
ما يحتاج ولا شي انت تقدر تغير تصميمه بس
كبرمجة هل انت تطبيقك عشان تقول ان اللي
جاهز تسويه في في مادري وشو في نظام اي
نظام سوا في حالت التشغيل مثلا افضل فذا
انت تقول ايه يلا بسم الله
انطلق عادي نعطيك تحيه بس في ناس ترى كثير
يفكرون فيها من ناحيه التكلفه بقوللك انا
ليش اجيب اربع مطورين اثنين ايوس اثنين
اندرويد اجيب واحد ولا اثنين هايبرد وخلاص
يعني وانا دائما ردي على هذول الناس ليش
لازم تسوي ايو اس واندرويد طيب ايه لما
ايش الفائده لما تروح تسوي في اللغه
الهجين هذه او اللغات الثانيه انك انت ما
يحتاج انك تطور تطبيق للاندرويد وتطبيق
اخر للاي اوس لا لا انت تسوي مره واحده
بعدين تضغط انه ايش تبغى الاجهزه فتضغط
هذه يسوي الواحد هنا وهنا على طول بغط سر
ش هذ اللغات
الهجين كلها سيف
يحبها لا يعني الاشهر في السوق عن الان ف
فلاتر من جوجل وفي نيتيف من
فيسبوك والنعم ها والعم ناس
ناس منحم طيبه حم طيب بالضبط لكن كفكره
وكسبت رائع صراحه نتمنى فعلا انه يصير بس
الى الان شوي في ناس رى الحين يصارخون ترى
قاعد يقولون لا فلاتر رهيب مره وممتاز
راحم اندرويد فلاتر ترى يعني فيس بس من
جوجل يعني والامور تمام والفريم وورك تمام
ويشتغل على ايوس تمام لكن ستل جزء كبير
تفقده انه
الاشياء الجديده اللي نظام في ايوس 17
مثلا الشورت كت اللي تطلع برا ولا حاجه زي
كذا صعب انه
لغه خنا نقول هايبرد تدعمها بما انه
النيتف اوردي طلعت فيها اصلا وتقدر تجربها
فتره عشان كذا تستمر
الى ويعني اذا واححد يبغى يسويها احيانا
في تطبيقات تنجح فيها بس اتوقع مادري
فيسبوك ظهر انهم نيتف صح
كانوا يعني رجعوا نيتف اتوقع فيسبوك سووا
لغتهم يعني فيسبوك يعني معقد جدا في كثير
يقوللك انستغرام وفيسبوك هم هجين ايه انا
اقوللك ايه بس ما تغ نفسك في فيسبوك يعني
يعني اتوقع بالراحه 100 انجنير من شغلين
على التطبيق اي يعني اكثر اكثر اكثر يعني
ما تقار نفسك في فيسبوك لا تقوللي فيسبوك
وانستغرام لغه الهايبرد اللي قاعد
يستخدمونها هي هم اللي بانين يعدلون حفيا
يعدلون على الليفل اللي فما عندك ما تق
نفسك فيهم يعني مو صح
[موسيقى]
شي طيب بس بنقارن نفسنا فيهم بحاجه
ثانيه في عندنا العمل عن
بعد وفي العمل في
المكتب عن قرب عادي هنا قشيخ والله ممتاز
بقوه سلطان يعني طيب تبغوا نبدا
من الكلاسيك
بالمنطق الكلاسيك فانت ضد العمل عن بعد لا
لا له اكيد 100%
استخداماته يعني الان نشتغل مع ناس عن بعد
عادي طبيعي جدا ولكن انا ارى انه لما تكون
عندكم مهمه ومهمه صعبه جدا لما يكون في
ناس متجمعين في مكان واحد في حاجب اتصالي
كبير يروح ومنها تطلع الابداع يب
يطلع لا يلا بسوي مكالمه لدرجه انه بعض
الناس في عن طريق عن بعد صاروا ايش يسوون
يفتحون تات ساعه ساعتين ثلاثه اربعه عشان
يحاولون يقعدون مع بعض تو ريكيت على
قولتهم انك في مكان واحد تعمل فانا من
الاشخاص اللي اعتقد خصوصا حط خطين تحتها
ستارت اب وجودكم مع بعض في البدايه في
تشكيل الفكره والهويه وال كلتشر حق الشركه
بشكل عام ما يضاهي الموضوع عن بعد بعدين
شوي شوي لما تكبرون اوكي تقدر تسوي موضوع
عن بعد هذا لكن يكون في اتليست شي هايبرد
يعني في شي يجمعكم فانا ممن في صراحه بشكل
مره كبير مندا يعني كانان دائما في
اقواس من قديم يعني ض من زمان احس ان شخص
قاعد وتشوفه وانا اشتغلت فيق ست سنوات معه
ترى ما اشتغل مكتب يومنا
بعض داما
بيت داما في المكتب
يعني طيب مساو عن بعد يعني هي هذه التواصل
يعني انه فكره احيانا احيانا شوف جهد اني
لازم ارسل رساله ولا جهد انه لازم اسوي
مكالمه عشان اناقش فكره معينه احيانا ما
يسوى اني اسويه فعجله ولا الغيه بشكل عام
وخلاص اتخذ قرار وامشي فيما بين انت في
المكتب لا احيانا النقاشات هذه السريعه
طبعا النقاشات هذه ممكن تصير مضره اذا
زادت وصارت خلص سواليف والاشياء زي كذا
ولكن اعتقد انه فائدتها اكبر بكثير من
الضرر انه لا خلاص انا بشتغل حالي فترات
معينه وبعدين بنجتمع ونعرض شغلنا وبيصير
فيه النقاش وشعور الديس كونكشن هذا شعور
انه انا ماني ضمن الفريق هذا انا ماني ضمن
الشيء اللي انا قاعد اسويه مهما كان يفرق
وتقدر تسال تقدر تسال انا انا اجزم ان لو
تسالت اي احد جرب ريموت من بعيد وبعدين
جرب انه يشتغل في نفس المكتب فرق كبير فرق
كبير في البرودكت فيتي فرق كبير بالتواصل
بينه وبين اعضاء الفريق بس يعني شوف 8 من
يوم بدات وهي شركه بعد من قبل كورونا
ممتاز ايه واعتقد ليه عندكم مكتب يعني
عادي خيار واحيانا انه في اشياء احنا لازم
نسويها اصورك
شلون بس يعني عادي نعمل عن بعد وحتى
احيانا تكون في الرياض وما يعني اقعد يمكن
اسبوعين ما اجي المكتب يعني عادي ف فانا
بختلف معك ودي احس علي عنده منطقه رائع
للعمل عن بعد بس بما انه فريقه يعمل عن
بعد 100% او حتى في صحيح صح مشاريعك
الثاني بس تصدر تمام ف طبعا انا اشتغل عن
بعد من زمان يعني سطان من 2000 وكم يعني
من يوم اشتغل عن بعد متعود على هذا طريقه
العمل يعني والادوات موجوده يعني ادوات
التواصل المكالمات كلها موجوده طبعا انا
افضل عن بعد لاسباب وطبعا لازلت يعني اتفق
مع سلطان جزئيا في بعض النقاط اللي هي في
العمل في المكتب يعني فعن بعد اول شي
التركيز يعني هذا الشيء انشرب فلوس صراحه
بالنسبه لي يعني احنا رجعت الكميه في مكتب
8 اسبيع من رجعت من السفر و مو قادر اركز
ابدا صاير اشتغل في البيت لا ارب ساعات
بعدين اجي المكتب عشان يعني اكون مع
الفريق واكون مع الشباب واحسس يعني
الساعتين اللي في البيت او الساعتين اللي
يكون لحالي تماما عن ار خمس ساعات في
المكتب بالراحه يعني خصوصا الازعاج
والسواليف كان المكتب حي في ناس كثير يعني
في اكثر من 20 30 شخص ونس كنت اعاني اذكر
يعني في سابك
والاتصالات الدور الدور اللي كنت فيه
الجناح
بالدور في 100 شخص يعني موطبيعيه الازعاج
والزحمه وتلاق الناسين سماعاته يعني كانك
شغال في البيت ما فرق كانك عن بعد اساسا
يعني كلهم يعني تخيل يعني انا هنا واحد 10
متر يتكلمون بعض سكايب يعني ليش جا المكتب
يعني عفي جا المكتب لانه ما في غرفه
اجتماع ما خلاص سكايب ثلاثه ك يعني كان
مره تجربه كانك تعمل عن بعدين فشوف
التركيز هذا صراحه شي مره مهم في العمل عن
بعد انا متفق معك يعني صحيح انه في مساو
بعد وفي محاسن يعني في كثير افكار تجي
سالفه تقولها وانت جالس كذا بس نزلتوا
تشربون قهوه وفي سالفه بتطلع يعني يعني
رائعه جدا فانا افهمها بس بس التركيز ترى
اتفق معك يعني انت انا اشتغل اقعد الى
الظهر اشتغل حالي في البيت اذا خلصت اجي
هنا لاني ادري انبي يعني ما بين جلسه ما
بين كذا ما بين حاجه غير ان المكان برضه
احنا حاطين له سياسات كيف انه تحافظ على
التركيز التركيز ترى يروح سهل انه انه اي
حد ياخذك من تركيزك وصعب انك ترجع من انك
وانت مركز في الشغله جس تكتب تخليني جس
اكتب فجاه واحد
نداني كيف ارجع اتفق معك 100% انا حتى في
كنت دائما اسولف عن الموضوع هذا كتاب ديب
وورك كيف انه اصلا ما تبدا تسوي افضل نوع
عمل الا بعد ما انك تقعد اتليست اربع
ساعات مركز مركز تركيزها كتام وهذه لها حل
لها حل بكل بساطه يعني الحين صاير فيه
البودز هذه ولا الغرف خل تكون مغلقه
موجوده في المكتب تقدر تدخل فيها وعلامه
لكل احد موجود انه انا احتاج اني اركز
واحتاج اني اشتغل بشكل غير منقطع وسياسات
المكتب انه انا اذا لابس سماعه حتى لو
ماني لا اسامع شيء لكن هذه علامه انه لا
تكلمني الا اذا في حاجه ضروريه ف طبيعي
جدا يعني التركيز انا اتفق معكم 100% لكن
هذا ما يعني انه ما اقدر اركز وانا موجود
في المكتب خصوصا البيئه الكويسه
بيئه غالبا الكوبرت انه وانت عندك مكتب
وكلكم جنب بعض صعبه جدا لكن بيئه الستارت
ابس غالبا لما يكون في اكثر من مساحه عمل
اقدر اشتغل باخذ لابتوبي وبروح للبود هذا
ولا باخذ غرفه الاجتماعات ولا بروح ولا
باخذها جهه المطبخ ولا الريست اريا هذه
وبقعد فيها انا انا انا كمبرمج احيانا من
اول كنت دائما احب اني اغير ما اقدر اقعد
مكانين ثلاثه نفس فتلاقيني كل شوي اخذ
لابتب واروح مكان ثاني فهذا الحاله موجود
يعني 100% وتقدر
تسويه يعني في الفيزيك لكن
لكن ما اعتقد انه تكون بعيد طول الوقت
لمجرد التركيز سبب كافي لانه بالاخير
رساله من
سلاك تقطع كل هذا الليي يبغى يوصلك بيكلمك
مكالمه م بيخليك غير ازعاجات البيت غير
موضوع انه انا تراني انا ماني في العمل
الان انا في البيئه يعني خلاص انا في
البيت الان مثلا ان يقنع امي اني جالس
اشتغل فوق الى الان سبع سنين لما استطع
تقول جالس فوق تعال مع اقول والله اشتغل
ما حد قاللك كيف تشتغل اقنعني 100% 100%
فهذه ترى والله صعبه صعبه جدا وصعبه حتى
انت لك شخصيا انك انت في البيت وانا قاعد
اشتغل يا اخي لا البيت بيت والعمل عمل انا
احيانا حتى انه عندي شغل ويكند اروح فيها
مقه صراحه واقعد هناك واشتغل ولما اخلص
ارجع البيت حاولت اني اسوي يت اب في البيت
انا والله عندي البيت متاح مره صراحه يعني
عندي بالعكس مسوي لي نفس المكتب اللي فوق
مكتب في البيت بصراحه رائع جدا خلاص اصلا
احس اوتوماتيك لا شعوريا بس حط اللابتب
اشتل بسوي شي ثاني بحجز تذكره بسوي شي لا
اروح اشتغل لا شعوريا
يعني شي جيد يعني انا اقوللك ان العمل عن
بعد تحدي يشوف كثير من الشركات يعني حتى
زوم اللي هي كل العمل عن بعد تم من خلاله
رجعوا عمل في المكاتب ابل
رجعت مادري القين جوجل فيسبوك سو حريقه
رجع بس صنع فيعني امره مختلف بعد لكن لكن
نقول انهم هم فشلوا في العمل عن بعد هذه
الشركات لانها شركات لا تقوم على العمل عن
بعد يعني ما هو ضمن ثقافتها العمل عن بعد
هو جاء جائحه وطارئ ومن ثم اجبرهم انهم
يروحون عن بعد فيوم صاروا عن بعد ما هي
الشركه مبنيه عليه فصار اكيد في لخبطه في
بغون يرجعون للاساس بس وشلون يصير البعد
هو على نطاقين ترى على نطاق الموظف و نطاق
الشركه بالنسبه لحس الشركه لازم ان
ثقافتها عمل عن بعد يعني مثلا زي سلاك انا
احس يعني ما يخليك ما ينتك تشتغل عن بعد
وانت عندك سلاك اسلاك الادوات اللي انت
تستخدمها تساعدك على العمل عنب ولا لا
لانه فيها التركيز والتشتت هذا لازم تضبطه
اثنين ان برضو العمليه الابداعيه تختلف
يعني من صناعه لصناعه تختلف فانا اعتقد في
العمليات الابداعيه والشركات الناش في ذا
المجال انه ما يفرق صدقوني يشتغل اهم شي
ان يشتغل في المكان اللي هو فيه غير غير
انه بيساعدك على استقطاب كفاءات من كل
مكان فالموظف تلقاه ما يبغى يطلع من
الدمام ولاي قاعد في جده احسنلك واحسن لان
في جده وانت قعد في الرياض
لكن وسياسات في الشركه فداخل الشركه مثلا
كيف تضمن
ان الناس اللي تداوم انه ما يفرق فانت
تبغى التواصل يكون ما بين الناس اللي في
المكتب واللي غير المكتب مضبوط فيجب انك
تضبط عمليه التواصل وهذا يخلي لازم الموظف
يكون عنده انضباط عالي الموظف اللي بدون
انضباط عالي ما يقدر يشتغل عن بعد عن بعد
يهلكه اذا عنده انضباط ذاتي احس انه بيصير
عمل عن بعد رائع ف تشتغل من اي مكان يعني
هذا الشيخ علي وهو الرئيس تقنيه يعني
ونبغى نطلق اهم منتج في تاريخنا كان اخر
اربع اشهور في اليابان يعني 100% فكيف كنا
بنسوي بدون وكان اداء رائع يعني ما حسينا
بالفرق 100% بس يعني يعني فقدنا دخلات على
قول علي مختلف علي تحديدا يعني مختلف وانا
ما اعتقد انه هذا السائد يعني ما شاء الله
الانضباط الداخلي وموضوع انه انا بشتغل
واشغل ساعه الشغل هذه موجوده عند علي بس
ما هي موجوده عند كل احد فانا عشان كذا
قاعد اقول لو تقول لي الاعم بشكل عام ايش
يضبط اكثر عن بعد ولا عن قرب لا انا بقول
انه مكتب وموجود لكن هل هذه ممكن تضبط
100% ممكن تط ولا وجربناها كثير وفي بدايه
اضطرينا اصلا من البدايه ولكن لما اشوف
الفرق بين الاثنين لما اشوف المخرج
والافكار بين هذه وبين هذه حتم هناك يا
رجل واي سي واي سي ليش ليه الحين متكيه في
سيليكون فالي مع انها حاولت انه اكثر من
مره تطلع ليش سيليكون فالي اصلا لين الحين
قاعد يصدر شركات رائعه انه كلهم حول بعض
في بيئه واحده يمشي ويقع واحد ويسولف معاه
اوه تعال ليش ما نسوي شي تروح اللقاءات
وكلها في مكان واحد البيئه تفرق 100% كل
ما كبرت البيئه وكل ما صغرت تفرق بيئه
البيت بيئه المكتب بيئه الهذا ف بيئه حسيه
موجوده تقدر تتحكم فيها اكثر بكثير من
بيئه تكون هذا وليس بالضروره ان ما تقدر
فانا ع يعني مع الثن لكن احب نصل الهجين
ترى الهجين ممتاز يعني برضه خلاص يعني
اعطي الخيار عن بعد وخلي في مكتب انا
الفتره هذه صاير متعصب خذ
قرار يا هنا يا هنا ما في ما في رمادي ما
في نحط الزر هذا ولا ما نحطه لا خلنا نخلي
خيار في الاعدادات يفتح الزر لا لا لا
ياف احسنت صح ولا لا معك تماما لان لانك
ما تدري يعني احس احيانا الهجين هي نفس
حتى البرمجه يعني ما افضل شيء انك كذا و
كذا لان عن
بعد بنك تبني كل الشركه على ذ الفكره او
نكتب نيها انهم موجودين 100% بس صح انا في
بس اقطع كلامك هو قال نقطع عن ان سلاك
سناك ما ينفع عن بعد شست هزت راسك على طول
انا حسس سلاك هو اللي يمكن عن بعد يا اخي
يعني هو يبدل موضوع المكان اللي يجمعنا
عرفت كيف سلاك يعني هو كلنا نرجع على كل
نتكلم فيه بس انها تنبيهات لا تنتهي تشعر
بانك اذا جلست ثلاث ساعات او اربع ساعات
بعيد عنه انك بترجع تلقى فيه 100 رساله
انا ما عاد اقدر القاها بتلقى انك ترجع
تشيك كل شويه عشان تشوف ايش الرسائل وعندك
كميه القنوات اللي لا يعني بس يوتر ويحفز
العمل بالرسائل التشات فما هي موثقه ما
اقدر ارجع كثير ترى صحيح انك اشتري
الانتربرايز لا لا لو تشتري اللي تبي بس
قصدي انه ما هي مجمعه في م كانان واحد في
الانز صادق يعني له بس انا اعتقد انا اخت
طبعا كثير يستخدمونه يعني هو من اشهر
التطبيقات في العالم قولي لا قيمه له لا
لا بالعكس بس ان
احنا يعني فمثلا احنا في الشركه ما نستخدم
هذه الاشياء مانعين التواصل عبر اي
تطبيقات هذه واتساب تليجرام ممنوع منعا
تاما وممنوع ان اي احد يتصل على اي
احد طيب ممنوع ما تقدر الا للط الا
للطوارئ الطوار تصير مره مرتين ثلاثه في
السنه فبصل عليه على طول ما شاء الله بس
ان الاصل ان اذا كلكم
مرتاحين وما في
ستس لا اذا انت حيا اذا الشركه تجلس طوارئ
طول السنه معنات في مشكله اكبر
منظفي ك الحين قاعد اقرا حق ماسك
البيوجرافي حق اخي والله الرجل هذا ح يعني
انت لو تقرا يمكن تنجن شفت كيف السنس
اجنسي انه كيف 24 ساعه يبغى حريقه حوله
يبغى الناس كلها متاهب في يعني فعجيب يعني
عكسك تماما صراحه وانا اتفق معه اكثر انه
كل ما الواحد حس باهميه الشيء وبعجن هذا
كل ما كان الناتج ويمكن اقيس على مقياس
شخصي صراحه انا من الاشخاص اللي تحت الضغط
انتج احسن انتاجات عكس انه اطيني سنه
سنتين ما اقدر اسوي شي بس ان اوه لا لازم
يلا الحين اليوم بكره بعده انتج فقسها على
سكيل اكبر لكن عكس اللي قاعد اقوله تمام
برفع عشان كذا هو يفرق يعني عادي يعني في
ناس يعني في ناس انت اذا بنيت ثقافه الضغط
والعمل على تحت الضغط تصبح هذا مكان
المنظومه واذا اي احد ما يمشي فيها بيطلع
والعكس يعني يعني يمديك توصل لتسيب بس انه
في مكان في النص او مكان اخر اللي هو
الانضباط ترى اذا احد يعني احنا حاطين
مثلا سياسه مثلا ان كل مهمه لها موعد
تسليم انت اذا اجلت اكثر من مرتين المهمه
بتنشل منك وبعدين يصير مسائله لس جالس
واضح ان في مشكله انك مات قادر تخلصها ف
مواعيد واضحه انضباط واضح وتخليك تقدر
تخلص الشغل بشكل اوكي فهي تتطلب قاعد
تبدلون ضغط بضغط مختلف يعني ضغط
افتراضي لا لازم انت تحط موعد لتسليم
المهمه مهمه مفتوحه تساوي انها ما هي مهمه
100% 100% فهي تحديات يعني في
بناء الفكره بس انها تخليه صعب يعني احس
هذه ترى فوائد العمل عن بعدرا التوثيق
ونقطه وضوح الخطب دائما يا اخي اذا اشتغلت
في المكتب تحس نشتغل سوا صح وبنج لكن
الخطه ما هي واضحه مره تكون اذا كنت عن
بعد انت تدري ان في اصلا مشكله في الاتصال
مشكله في التواصل بشكل عام مع الموظفين
فلازم تكون واضح بقدر المستطاع رسائلك
واضحه جدا كل النقاط تغطيها فخلاص تكون
غطيت هذا هذا الجزء بكون كل خطه واضحه
فهذه جاب بعد فعلا فعلا وتبحث على الرسائل
ولا تبحث عن بالض كل شيء موجود كل شيء
موجود طيب بما اننا حديثين عهد
بتقنيه كم صار الدراهم كم
سنتين فالحين كيف تدير الاولويات اليوم
يعني كميه المزايا
والخصائص الجديده اللي ودنا نضيفها
للتطبيق لا تنتهي وكل واحده تقول انا احسن
اوكي بس في الاخير في موارد محدوده ووقت
محدود
ف كيف نحدد الاولويات كيف تتغلب على رغبتك
الشخصيه في انك تبغى تحط هذه الميزه مقابل
هذه الميزه فانت في الاخير بتختار واحده
من عشره حكيم يعني صادق دائما ودك تسوي
اشياء كثير ليه الحين دارك مود نبغى نسويه
وكل مره نخليه بعدين بعدين بعدين ولكن
دائما السؤال اللي يطرح نفسه
في لما نخطط عش الاشياء اللي نبغى
نسويها ش اهم شيء اب اقيسه او ابح عن طريق
التطبيق وعاده يكون اجابته بزنس ولا يكون
اجابته مقياس عش الاداء انا ابغى اسوي
ابغى عدد مستخدمين اكتف اكثر ابغى عدد ناس
يسمعون بودكاست اكثر يعني حددوا الرقم هذا
اتوقع واول ما يحدد الرقم هذا طيب الفيتشر
هذه الميزه هذه قدش بتاثر على الموضوع هذا
بكل بساطه يعني ودائما السؤ الجواب ما
يكون يعني دائما واضح ولكن انت تعرف وتحس
في الشيء هذا انه لو عدلت اللون
غالبا ما بيفرق غالبا ما بيخلي الواحد
يقعد عشان هذا اللون تعدل ولا تضبط ولكن
لو حطيت موضوع السماع عن طريق الباك
جراوند على جولت هو اني احمل قبل ما انه
يدخل الحاجه زي كذا هذا موست لايكلي انه
بيخليه هذه هي يعني دائما ودائما يكون في
نقاش صراحه احنا عندنا دائما اجتماع
اسبوعي كامل كل الفريق يجتمع فيه مع انه
ما نحب الاجتماعات الكثيره ولكن كون وجود
هذا الاجتماع الوحيد اسبوعيا كل احد يفكر
وكل احد يتكلم
ويناقش الميزات تحديدا يخلينا نعرف
الاولويات عرفت كيف كل واحد يقول ودي ودي
ودي ودي لكن بالنهايه نعرف شش الشيء اللي
يتكرر بشكل كبير وهذا الشيء اللي نسوي
يعني ف بس اوكي هل عندكم المترك هذا ولا
احنا عندنا ما ادري لا عندنا اطلقنا يعني
احنا من ناحيه كيف نحدد يعني تو اطلقنا من
الحين ثلاث اسبيع او كم اسبوع اسبوع ونص
الحين اطلقنا او داخليا لنا ثلاث اسابيع
تقريبا شهر
ا ف اول خلينا نقول متطلبات كلها من افكار
الداخليه يعني عبد الرحمن انا يعني الفريق
بشكل عام كلنا ندخل في اختيار هذه
المتطلبات تمام الان بعد ما ا طلقنا فتحنا
باب الاقتراحات طبعا كنا مترددين حتى عبد
الرحمن كان عنده يعني توجس من الموضوع لكن
اضفنا كذا يعني ما توقعت هذا القدر يعني
الى الان في خلال اربع خمس ايام وصلنا
اكثر من 150 اقتراح ماشء الله فال
المستخدمين مره مطلبين الامانه وهذا شي
جيد صراحه و بشيء سلبي فنقدر وبرضه عندنا
قاعد ناخذ بيانات كثيره مستخدمين طبعا
بدون عرفه من هو المستخدم لكن قاعد ناخذ
ايش ضغط عليه متى الساعه كم ايش القائمه
دخل عليها ايش البرنامج دخل عليه فعندنا
خلينا نقول بيانات ممتازه تخذ فيها قرارات
وايضا زي ما ذكرت عندنا عندنا افكارنا
الموجوده اوريدي سويها واقتراح المستخدمين
واحنا نشتغل بنظام دورات لمده الدوره
شهر طويل بس اوكي تقريبا سبرنت مره طويله
شهر تقريبا حلو ممتاز بس يعني الفكره انه
نجلس نبني اكثر يعني الافكار يعني نخطط
[موسيقى]
ونبنيها بس معناته ان بصير التحديث كل شهر
كل شهر بصير تحديث التطبيق يعني العاده
انه في شركات كثيره اتوقع اوبر وكثير منهم
كل اسبوعين اسبوعين اسبوعين كل اسبوع
اسبوع كل
اسبوع ولا فعلا مميز شي
ميز
بسش
والله هو يكفي ترى هل في صوت في
المكتب لا والله لا والله الشباب سعيدين
اول
حاجه اول حاجه انا يعني محظوظ جدا بالناس
اللي اشتغل معاهم متحمسين احيانا يفوق
حماسي اللي انا وانا اوردي اعتبر جدا
متحمس الشيء هذا فغالبا ما يحتاج الانسنتف
لموجه
لكن لا حرفيا صدق والله لكن يعني انا انا
من الناس اللي صراحه ماني في البدايه
خصوصا من الحين نعتبر نفسنا في البدايات
بروسيس ونقاش وتخطيط كثير ما يحتاج له
اللي يحتاج انه نطلع بالميزه اسرع وقت
ممكن عشان نشوف فعاليتها ونطلع باقل
المتطلبات الممكنه اذا شفنا انه الميزه
رائعه والناس بدات تستخدمها وبدات تعطي
ملاحظات عليها رائع كيف نحسن الميزه هذه
اكثر واكثر فهذا اللي مسوي طبعا مو الميز
لازم بس اسبوع وتطلع احيانا الميزه تقعد
شهر لكن جزء منها يتم في الاسبوع الاول
جزء منها يتم في الاسبوع الثاني بس وعرفني
هنا مثلا ميزه دراهم وقوللي كم تاخذ عشان
تخلص عشان برضه نفهم اكثر احنا يعني بحرفي
احنا بطلع بميزه جديده الحين الواجهه
غيرناها وضبطنا في في كم
حاجه هذه ميزه كامله يعني هذه
تغييرك ش شكل الرئيسيه لا هو موك يعني
اشياء داخل اشياء تغير اكثر وهذ هذه كانت
ايتم يلا ايش الاشياء اللي تحتها يحتاج
يحتاج لها ديزاين يحتاج لها
فبنت خلصت اسبوع خلصت باسبوعين تقريبا
لكنه في
البدايه خليني بعطيكم اتوقع الكاتش هنا ما
يبدا الا الديزاين يكون جاهز اي فانت ما
الديزاين ترى ضمن الاليه ضمن
الشهر شي ترى الديزاين دائما يعني بالاخير
انت بتسوي ديزاين وبتقرير وتناقش فيه صعب
صعب انك تحكمه فانا عشان كذا انه سبرنت
اللي يبدا عاده يكون فيه تاسكات ديزاين
لكن اكثر التاسكات اللي تتاخر وتندفع
لطبيعتها الديزاين صح صح صحيح بس احنا
نعطيه اول شي اسبوع ايه اللي هو تحديد
يعني فكره الدوره ش المزايا فكرتها كمنتج
ليش الميزه هذه نبغى نسويها ليش هذه نبغى
نحطها كيف نتوقعها ش اثرها على المستخدم ش
اللي احنا نتوقع منها كتفاعل فانت ترسم
الفكره كميزه مو كيف تشتغل معي مو نقاشنا
بس ان فتيجي تقول انا ابغ اسوي هذا هذا
لانه بياثر على ناس هنا نتوقع انه بياثر
على هذول وبكذا نبغى نزيد التفاعل اكثر ون
نسو فنعطيه وثيقه الهويه خلال اسبوع وثيقه
الدوره خلال اسبوع هذه تسلم المصممين اول
شيء ف مصممين يشوفونها وعليها
يعكسون الفكره الى تصميم ما نعرف كيف
بيطلع تصميم بس هذا دورهم وفي مدير
المصممين هو اللي يتخذ القرار عنده في
اسبوع صح صحيح في اسبوع يخلص التصميم ط
احنا ينتقل اذا طلع من التصميم نادر انه
يرجع الا اذا انه ما يشتغل بس المصممين
يدرون كيف
يعني المصمم سينير ان يعني فاهم بالضبط
كيف الجوال يشتغل فما بيصمم شيء غير قابل
للتنفيذ لكن انه بس بيراجع بيتاكد يمكن
يقولون لا بس ما تضبط كذا هل نقدر نغيرها
يصير بس الاصل خلاص انهم يخلصون مبرمجين
هذه ويختبرون ونطلق شوف اذا اخذت وقت كافي
تقدر تطلع بتص ميم على قته ما يخرش الميه
خلاص كل شيء تمام وجاهز والتفاصيل فيه انا
من الناس اللي تؤمن انه مح ما سويت تصميم
في وقت يعني قياسي بالاخير لما تجربه غير
ولما تجي تطوره غير اوه طيب ليش وتدخل ديب
تكنيكال كوشنز انه طيب لو خليت السكرول من
هال الطريقه بدل هال الطريقه طب لو خليت
هذا فوق هذا هل طب اذا طلعته فوق شوي
اللون هذا بيتعدل كيف بيصير فجزء لا يتجزا
من التطوير هو محادثه المصمم مع المطور
فهي ما المصمم يعطي تصميم وخلاص المصمم
يعطي تصميم معنا انه الفكره اكتملت مبدئيا
فخلينا نبدا التطوير فعندنا في تراهم ترى
قائد الموبايل مع قائد التصميم 24 ساعه
كلمه 24 ساعه طب هذه كيف طب هذه كيف طب
عدل طيب بدل ويرجع ويرجع ويرجع ويرجع ليه
ما تطلع الميزه بالاخير فانا عشان كذا
قاعد اقول انه ما ودي ناخذ وقت مره كثير
في البدايه نطبخ الميزه ونحدد تفاصيلها مع
ان اريح للمطورين اريح بكثير
للمطورين بل ناخذ وقت اكثر بتجربه الميزه
بتجربه على طول انا تخوفني هذ ترى ضد فكره
التجارب السريعه تنفع في اماكن تنفع بس
انها يعني مثلا في التطبيق كم اخذنا يعني
ظهر اول مهمه كنت موجود فيها
21 ف فلنا الحين سنتين اللي انا اطلقنا
التطبيق فخذ وقت كان يمديك تقول انه نزله
وخلي الناس تختبره وتشوف اذا الناس حبوه
ولا لا باقل كلفه باقل يعني كذا اذا الناس
حبوه تمام فطور اذا ما حبوه ما في مشكله
وهذه اتوقع انها فلسفه جوجل بعد فهم
ينزلون الخرايط ينزلون 60 مليون حاجه يجون
يحذفون 20 منتج كل سنه شوف والجيد يكملونه
يصممون
ويطورون لكن هذه احسنها ما تنفع كثير
تخوفني انها ممكن الميزه زينه والفرضيه
اللي عليها بنيت الميزه حلوه بس لان
التنفيذ ما كان بالشكل مثالي الناس ما
استخدموها فتظن ان الناس ما يحبونها بس ما
هو بان الناس ما يحبونها انت ما سويتها
زين 100% 100% واصلا دائما يجي السؤال هذا
ولا ادعي اني اعرفه ترى دائما يجي السؤال
لما ميزه تطلع على سبيل المثال والناس ما
تستخدمها هل لانه المنتج مو بزين هل لانه
فشلت اوصل الميزه تسويقيا للناس انها
تستخدمها هل لانه الناس ما يحتاجون الميزه
هذه اصلا من البدايه ففي كم سؤال صعب جدا
انت تحط متركس وتشوف كيف تحرك صعب جدا انك
يعني تعرف الشيء هذا ولكن دائما التجربه
خير دائما التجربه بتعطيك بتعطيك اتليست
توجه انه ترى غالبا المشكله هنا غالبا
الناس ما فهموها غالبا الناس ما ما
يبغونها اصلا فتبدا تسوي شيء ثاني حس تحدي
يعني في تطبيقات بشكل عام ما تعرفوا شو
الصح يعني في تطبيقات طلعت قبل اربع سنوات
الناس كروح بعد اربع سنوات وتشوف نجحوا
بينما قب سوات فشل ما تعرف ليش يعني
الخلطه هذه ما تدري يمكن هو السوق يمكن هو
المنصه يمكن هو التطبيق الهويه ما ادري
تموضع حقك يعني في عوامل كثيره ما تعرفها
يعني 100% واقرب مثال في كورونا شو اسمه
ذاك الراديو اللي انتشر فجاه كب هاوس هابس
انتشر كنار في الهشيم يا رجل كل حد حمله
خلصت راح حرفي اختفى ف الفكره هذه انه ترى
عوامل عديده جدا فانا اللي احاول انه
اطبقه دائما لا تاخذ وقت كثير تفكر لانه
في عوامل ما هي في يدك
وبالاخير تكلفه اني اقعد وقت طويل وبعدين
اجرب وممكن هالشي ما يضبط بالنسبه لي
احاول اني اقللها قد ما اقدر فعشان كذا
بطلع فيها باسرع وقت اخذ اجابات من الناس
واشوف كيف اله وتبدا عاد تسوي طريقه تبدا
طريقه يسمونها الرول اوت انه خلاص ميزه ما
احنا متفقين فيها 100% ما بطلعها لكل
المستخدمين بطلعها ل 10% 5% من المستخدمين
واقدر ارجعها بشكل سريع فهذه هذه ط او حتى
اي بي تستين برض اي بي تستين يس انك تطلع
لي جزء مستخدمين شكل ومستخدم الاخرين بشكل
اخر بناء الارقام والحصيات تقرر اللي تبي
100% هذ اذا مره مره انت خايف من لكن ا
احس انه اصمل اصمل طيب بالنسبه لي سلطان
واضح كيف يدير فريقه ش يسوي يسكر عليهم
الباب ما تطون تخلص الز في اسبوع اسكر معي
اسكر على نفسي
[ضحك]
معهم بس كيف كيف تدير فريقك وهو يعمل في
مدن مختلفه وعن بعد وعندك هذه التحديات جد
اول شيء احس التحدي الاكبر اللي قبل اصلا
فريق ومن هو الفريق كيف وضفت الفريق احس
هنا التحدي الاكبر اصلا كيف لقيت الاشخاص
المناسبين انك تشتغل معهم فمان توضي جدا
صعب خصوصا في الاور التقنيه احس تحدي مره
كبير اول شي انك تلاقي شخص مناسب تقنيا
بعدين تلاقي شخص مناسب من ناحيه تصرفات
واتيتي ان يقدر يشتغل عن بعد يعرف يتواصل
كتابته جيده جيد مع الفريق يعرف يوصل
افكار بشكل جيد مجتهد يحب يتعلم يعني هذه
الصفات ما تلقيها في كل الناس اليوم صراحه
المانه الامور التقنيه احس اي احد يتعلمها
بسرعه اربع شهور ست شهور بيكبر وبيتعلم
حبه حبه لكن الشخصيه وتصرفاتهم سهل تغيرها
مع الوقت متناغمه مع ثقافه الشركه مره
يعني هذا تحدي مره كبير فعلا واللي اسميه
الحدس لما يكون التقني فاهم في المنتج
وعارفه وعنده اراء عليه دائما تلاقي
التنفيذ افضل بكثير لو انه ولا سويلي ا
100% دائما اقول هذا في خطا دائما يصير في
كل فرق الت سابقا حتى يصير عندنا اللي كت
مطلبات ينسى شي معين او كتب شي خاطا
المصمم يروح يصمم هذا الخطا يعني ما ركز
او يعني مو فاهم بعدين يجي المطور يطور
هذا الخطا والمختبر يختبره هو خطا يعني بس
انه ما يشوف انه خطا لانه ممكن واحد ما
يستخدمون تطبيق او ما يعرفون ش ف مو جيد
برضو يعني احس هذ حده من الاشياء ان
يعني
انه اذا المطورين والمصممين ما هم مؤمنين
بالفكره وما هم مؤمنين بهدف التطبيق وهدف
الشركه وما يستخدمونه اذا ما اول مستخدمين
ف
منطقط ومو فاهم اسباب يعني هذا جزء كبير
ليش القرارات هذه قاعد تصير ليش التغيير
هذا قاعد يصير اذا الواحد ما هو مقتنع
وترى الاساس الاساس المطور هو بالاخير هو
اللي بيحول شيء الى واقع اذا ما هو مقتنع
فاشيا كثيره ما بتضبط لانه بتلاقي بالاخير
بالاقتراحات اغلبها تجي من المطورين ميز
كثيره طلعناها انه المطور فاهم الشي هذا
100% فيجي يقوللك اسمع ترى هذا ممكن وهذا
مو ممكن هذا خلنا نعدل كذا طب في ميزه
جديده نزلت ليش ما
نسويها فاكبر تحدي هذا انك تلاقي ناس
ممتازين يفهمون يقدرون يشتغلوا معك ونس
طريقتك يعني طبعا معظمهم لان المهارات او
المواهب قليله في السوق فاسعار غالي اي
اسعارهم جدا غاليه والله يسوون والله
مبالغات الفتره الاخيره في مبالغات يعني
صد قدي انه يكون في كثير لان اللي موجود
الان عدد
قليل والتنافس عليهم ضخم جدا ف يروحون عن
دراهم عندهم دراهم واجد انا اتوقع اذا
كانت ميزتك التنافسيه لوظيفه اني انا بدفع
راتب اكثر فانت راح تخسره بعد اقل من سنه
راتب احسن يعني ف يعني اصلا يعني هذه ف
عشان كذا ما اشوفها تحدي التحدي انك تقنع
الشخص الرائع اللي راتبه العالي جدا
بالفكره وب هدف لدرجه انه يقبل بحصه في
الشركه ويكمل معك هذا هذا التحدي في
التوظيف صح وترى في ناس كثير يعني يعني
حتى معان فريق في ثمانيه مو موجود عشان
الراتب او ما غيره يمكن البيئه الهدف حق
الشركه ثقافه الشركه مره عاجبته وحتى عن
بعد ناس كثير يعني يج معان بس عشان احنا
عن بعد فخلاص عنده هذا الخيار فهو مبسوط
عليه مره كنت دائما اقوللكم ادري قلت الشي
هذا كثير و لكن موضوع انه احس محظوظين في
التوظيف انت المفروض لانه كثير يسمع محتوى
ثانيه وياثر عليه فيكون اتاش اكثر يعني ف
مماتكم هنا المفروض ان تكون الحممدلله
اسهل
بكثير فهنا هذا اول نقطه قلنا الفريق يعني
في معلش في كانت واحده من التحديات عندنا
في الفريق واحس علي
يعنيان معها انه كل ما قابلنا
احد يعني صعب يقتنع ان يعني انت تصوم
احبكم والله بس انت تصوم يعني محتوى يعني
انا بغير
طريقي المهني يعني شيسوي عندكم تقول لا
عندنا مدري ايش تشرح له يعني صعب يقتنع
احيانا انه يغير لانها ما يشوفها تقنيه
بحته بس المساله اليوم بعد الاعلان احس
انها تغير بعد الاطلاق كثير جلدن كلموني
اوه ما شاء الله عن تطبيق رهيب متوظف
عندكم ما تقاعدت في
ثمانيه تغيرت النظره الحين فالحين خلص من
نقطه توظيف واختيار الفريق الحين نجي
لموضوع عيات العمل طبعا نشتغل عن بعد يعني
ف عندنا اول تحدي ان الناس ماهم مجودين
حولي او ما احد حول احد اصلا فلازم ان كل
شي يكون واضح يعني بالتفصيل يعني زي ما
ذكرت عبد الرحمن قبل ان اول شي نقضي اسبوع
خلينا نقول في خلنا نتكلم عن اليه العمل
عندنا تشكيل اولا فخلاص يعني مع مدراء
المنتجات انا وعبد الرحمن نقعد نحاول نفصل
الفكره بقدر المستطاع ف نطلع مستند يعني
يمشي على كل خلينا نقول المسارات اللي في
التطبيق او مسارات هذه الميزه بيها بعدين
نوديه لتصميم صمموه ونراجع معهم ونعتمد
بعدين التطوير وهكذا انا علي كيف ادير
الفريق ا انا عندي خلينا
نقول خلينا نقول ي شكل لست يومي حرفين كذا
قائمه يوميه كاتبها في نوشن قدامي اول ما
ابدا خلاص تشيك مثلا التنبيهات تشيك
الايميلات تشيكيك مادري ايش شو امشي عليها
قامه لك مو ل ليي انا امشي حبه حبه حبه
حبه ومنها مثلا امشي على مهام الموظفين
اتاكد ان كل شيء ماشي صح
التواريخ صح اراجع المهام القديمه فعندي
مثلا الخميس قبل قبل ام تقريبا مشيت على
كل المش القديمه امشي واتاكد ان كل مهمه
تمت كل مهمه لها تاريخ هذا كل يوم كل خميس
كل خميس كل
خميس اراجع كل اول شي ان علي ما ينطبق علي
لا ينطبق عل اي انسان في 100% اخي
المستمع ليس انسان والله ما شاء الله ماشء
الله ما شاء الله لا اله الا الله يبارك
لك ويحفظك يا ربعن لكنك من كوكب اخر يعني
احب اكون يعني ما هو ميكرو مانجمنت ماني
مره معقد لا بقدر ما اني احب اعرف كل شيء
ما ب اتاكد وا اغثك لا لازم اعرف كل شيء
فلازم اتاكد كل واحد اي قاعد يسوي واتاكد
من كل التواريخ موجوده صح كل مهام مكتوبه
اتاكد اذا في احد رد وما رد عليه اتاكد من
كل شيء هذا كل خميس كل سبت عندي مراجعه
للاسبوع الجاي فاكد ان الدورات واضحه
التصميم جاهزه الكود صار ل ميرج اتاكد من
كل شيء كذا فاكون نص الاسبوع
غالبا للطوارئ والاشياء يعني اللي في
لحظتها فالواحد سوي منشن لو واحد كلمني
اتواصل معه لكن الاشياء الاخرى اخلي لها
وقت الخاص خ نقول اللي هو وقت التركيز ما
ذكرنا في البيت خلاص هذا عشان اركز اشوف
الاشياء المهمه في مثلا عبد الرحمن طلب من
شي مثلا شي شي مستقبلي تصميم سو جديد ولا
جديده احتاج افكر فيها فخلاص هذ بيني وبين
نفسي ماخليها وقت العمل اللي دائما
الناسجون فيه ا عشان كذا احب اداوم قبل
الناس داوم ساعتين فحب اداوم مره بدري
يعني اغلب الناس في الثمانيه ت 10 اداوم
7عه 6 عشان اكون مغطي كل شي عندي ما احب
اتاخر ناس في الرد مره مضح يوترني مره
يعني انا ما احب اح اتخر في الرد فانا
يعني مبدئي خلاص انا ارد الناس بسرعه
فعندي خلينا نقول ثمان ساعات الى 24 ساعه
ماكسيموم ارد على الناس حتى الايميلات
يعني مع انصص الايميلات
كثير فاللي اسويه خلاص بقول برد عليك ذاك
اليوم بحاول اني يرد عليه عشان اطمنه ا
الا طبعا يعني في الاملات ما تخلص حق
الشركات هذه خلاص صرت هذه اعتزلت اتوقع
كلنا توصلنا هذه اللي احنا شركه خدمات نبي
احنا عندنا مطورين يعني خلاص لامانه سبام
اي يا اخي كثير مره فانا اعتر منكم يعني
عد تسمعونه انا حبيت انك لا لا لا تعتذر
لا تعذر لا حد يرسل ايلات بدم بس العجيب
انه كان يرد عليهم اي لا ارد يعني هو
الحين يعتذر انه بطل ير احيانا احيانا انت
واضح ماخذ اسم الشركه من لينكدين زي ما هو
يعني ما يعرف زوني مره صراحه ذول بس اني
احرص كل رساله اقراها بتمعن وارد عليها
بشكل كامل
الاانه فقط هذه تق
تقريبا احاول اني اكون انسان مع
الناس هو انحول يصير
معناهم لا هي نقطه نقطه لازم تفهم الناس
احيانا صح
يعني احاول اني افهم الناس قبل ما صبين
الناس احيان
والله كم جلست تتعرف
على والله يعني تحدي صراحه لا يعني في
تحدي ترى الموضفين ما هم سواسيه الناس ما
هم سواسيه بشكل عام يعني فيعني لازم تتطبع
بخلينا نقول طباعي او طريقه اداره معينه
مع كل شخص ففي شخص عنيد مثلا لا في شخص
يمكن ما عنده راي ت تطلع راي منه فتتعب
تكلم يعني خلاص كل واحد له طريقه معينه في
التعامل معه يعني واتوقع هذا كلنا يعني
اذا بندير ناس
يفرق مثلا شخص تعرف انه خلاص دبره ما احت
اشرح كثير فلان خذ هذه المهمه ويلا ما
تشرح له في ثاني لا لازم تقعد تفصله كل
التفاصيل مهمه يعني في شخص اخر يمكن هو
دبره لكن يسال مره كثير يطف شك يمكن
احيانا يقدر يسالك 50 سؤال وتلاقي كذا
يعني فكل شخص وكلهم صح ماقول واحد غلط لكن
لازم يعني انت كشخص تعرف كيف تدير كل شخص
منهم بطريقه انت شرحت نظامك انت الشخصي
كيف نظامك مع الفريق طيب كيف اليومي ولا
اي لا لا خلاص انا معهم سواء ما عندنا
اجتماعات احنا كثير ا يعني عندنا اجتماع
اسبوعي تسكات موجوده وخلاص لا يعني في
اجتماع اسبوعي اجتماع اسبوعي مخليه لان
احنا عن بعد فما نشوف بعض اوك فالهدف مه
الاساسي ان نتكلم مع بعض اوكي في تحديات
احيانا ما ما تكتبها في المنشن او ما
تكتبها في البيس كامب او يعني ما تطلع منك
فخلي هذا الاجتماع بس عشان نقدر نتواصل مع
بعض وطبعا الحضور اختياري والكل يحضر يعني
ما في احد ما يحضر يعني ف حضور افض يحضرون
اجتماع افتراضي اللهون اجتماع افتراضي مو
هو اجتماع يعني على
طول تبى تدور شي ياكد فكرتك اس لا لكن اي
الكل يحضر يعني عشان بس نتواصل مع بعض
يعني خلاص المصمم وده يقول شي بس مو بعارف
يكتبه جربتوا حركه طيب البير بروجرامينج
اللي يشغلون الكاميرات مع بعضون س والله
عندي شباب بالموبايل الاس مع بعض وور مع
بعض دائما كذا يعني كل يوم ست ساعات مع
بعض يجربونها كثير
ح يك مع بعض مفيده مره حسيت يعني ان ناهيك
عن العمل قاعد ينجز بشكل ممتاز انه
علاقتهم قت مع بعض دائما ه التحدي عن بعد
يكون الموظفين تس رفون
بعض عشان ك نسوي حفله السنوي نجمع كل
الناس عشان خلي نقول نعرف بعض يعني جزء
منها نسوي شتاء ثانيه مده ثلاث ايام ارب
ايام مسافر دائما ما حد قاللك تسافر جان
داما لا لا مو بجاني هو خله يقعد ايب
ادريبه انا ت اقوله يقوللي يعني خلاص خلاص
لا توقف سفر وقف سف يقولل الاسبوع الجاي
بروح الاسبوع الماضي كان مسافر بعد اسب ما
شاء الله يعني خلاصنا معك اكثر واحد قاعد
في اله يا اخي ما اسافر كثير انا هو اكثر
واحد قاعد في كورونا ترى ما حد طلع في
السعوديه الا هو ما حد طلع اي بس فعوض
شوي وين راح اس جاي امريكا ان شاء الله اخ
شوف والله اقوللك روح خمس مرات مرا وقبله
تى في ايطاليا مدري فرنسا يعني ما شاء
الله متى كنت انا في ايطال اوروبا مادري
وين السن اللي راحت قبل اسبوعين ت
[ضحك]
راحله يا سلطان
الله مو مشكله مو مشكله طيب من اللي قفل
الباب عليهم اذا سافرت والله اق
الشش انا ارفض هذ النوش هذ الفكره الشباب
رائعين اد
لا هو صدق والله انت قلت انواع اشخاص
الشخص الفاهم اللي عنده اونر شيب عاليه
اللي عنده كذا انا اعتقد انه غالبيه اللي
احب اشتغل مهم بالتالي غالبيه اللي
موجودين في دراهم عندهم هال الحس العالي
منما يحتاج تتابع ماحتاج تقفل ماحتاج ان
شاء الله تسوي شي بالعكس اذا ما هم قفلوا
عليك اسمع هذا الشيء انت موقفه ضبط اياه ف
يا اخي والله المسؤوليه مره مهمه في
الموضوع يعني يمكن هذه المهارات الناعم
ذكرت في البدايه مره يهمني ان ما يحتاج
خلينا نقول هي بشبل يعني في يعني بدف
وبتسحب في ناس لازم تسحبهم العمل في ناس
لاهم يدفون العمل فيا اخي يعجبونك
المسؤولين الاشخاص المسؤولين طبعا هذه حتى
فريش تلاقي جدا مسؤول يعني ما هي بالخبره
فيريحك مره يا اخي خلاص ما تشيل هم تدر ان
الشغله بتخلص هو بنفسه مسؤول بيمسك كل شيء
بيروح يكلم لك كل الناس حرفيا بيكلم ناس
ما تعرفه يمكن بيخلص الشغل عشانك بس وهذه
جزء
منها يعني الليدر نفسه او الشخص اللي
مسؤول انه حط ه الحس لان دائما المسؤول
اذا اعطيته مسؤوليه زياده اذا وثقت فيه
اكثر اذا شاف انه فعلا قراره له وزن يزيد
وبالتالي الشخص اللي لا دائما يقول ولا
دائما هذا يرفض ولا ما تلاقيه لا خلاص طيب
انا بسوي تب وخلاص يعني وينقلب عكس تماما
صعب جدا انك توازن بين هو في انسان مسؤول
وفي انسان
غير لا بس والله في انسان مسؤول احيانا
المنظمه ما تخليه كل ما فلسف كل ما تكلم
كل مادق على راسه اكثر يعني وشز هذا الشي
عشان كذا قاعد اقول انه احيانا نفس
المنظمه ما قاعد تستخدم ناس رائعين عندها
لهالسبب تتبع البروسس ولا تتكلم مشكله
تقتتل الناس احيانا يعني في ناس اعرفهم في
بدايات الكرير حقهم طاحوا في الشركات قتلت
هذا الحس عندهم فخلاص احس صاروا كسولين مو
كسولين يعني ما ود يطلع من دائره الراح
هذه خلاص انا النمله اللي اسوي شغلي
الصغير هذا مره خلاص اكتفي فيه يعني فيعني
للاسف والله في حزني ه
اجين انا
ارفض كلنا بشر حبيبي حبيبي بشر ق
شيو كان يعني يعطيك مثال تشبيه تشبيه
انالوجي تشبيه يعني مشكله كل خليه النحل
اتليست خليه النحل يلا نحله وخليه النحل
النمل والله النمل تمييز تجاه النمل ايش
فيهم النمل لا ابد ما فيهم شي والله مت
النمل يعني مخلوقات ومخلوقات الله
وال احيان النمله يعني اتوقع ان يندعس علي
ياشوف ك بالعكس انا اشوف النمله ممتازه
تشيل اضعف جسم اربع مرات يعني عنده مز جدا
كبيره وبعدين جروب ورك عمل جماعي جدا رهيب
يسوون ما تداك زيهم تمز تمييز
مرفوض تسحب يلاو مشكله كلنا
[ضحك]
نلنا بس
علي الحين ركزنا احنا التطبيق بس عندنا
التطبيق الموقع الموقع و في منتج ثالث لم
يعلم بعد يعني نحاول نبني ايكو سيستم او
منظومه محتوى منظومه تقن رحت الويب ورحت
ايش باقي بعد يا اخي ترقب ترقبت يلا مو
مشكله ما في حتى بيته ولا تست فلايت ولا
شيء يلا مو مشكله عندك بودكاست عندي
بودكاست اه انا كشخص نقول بودكاست ولا تطك
تي بكاست نشوف اوكي خلاص تمام ف ف تلميحه
تكفي
يعني بس الفكره هي كيف نقدر نضبط
منظومه
تقنيه سعوديه عربيه تساعد الناس انهم
يصنعون محتوى ممتاز فهذا في تحدي دائما
احنا نواجه في ثمانيه في جسين نبنيه من
جديد لانه يساعدنا بالدرجه الاولى فاحنا
اول ناس نبغى نستخدمه وبيساعد الناس
بالضروره فيما بعد انهم يستخدمونه
فثلاث منتجات احس ان في تحدي يعني خصوصا
كل حد ظهر ما يتقاطعون كثير اي
صحيح قبل ودي اسال ودي اسال كيف ما قبل
الفكره وما بعد الخروج والناس تجرب والفيد
باك هذا طيب قبل انت كيف شفته انت انت
تتذكر زمان بدينا انفصلت شفت بشكل نهائي
يس انا اتذكر من زمان بعدين شفت نسخه شاف
النص هو كنا في استراحه يوم من الايام سوا
قب ان وريت شيء في النص ما عجبها بد كانت
اعتياديه لكن لطيفه يعني لكن اللي طلع
رائع جدا الشي اللي صراحه عجبني فيه انه
فعلا محاوله يعني نافيجيشن ال وايز حتى
ستركشر انه ا مختلف انت حاط لي اثنين فوق
بعض واقدر اتنقل ما بينها موضوع الصاله
وكيف اني اقدر اعلق واشوف ف تطور رهيب
واضح انه يعني اللي انا استشفيت انه يصير
في نسخه تجربونها ما تعجبكم ولا ترقى الى
التط
تعيد مره ثانيه مرهق طع ما طلعته بنسخه
ترى النمط الداكن الدارك مود يعني يمكن
سوينا منه ولا 30 نسخ كير م من لون اللون
من لون بعدين نتفق على لون بعدين يجي بندر
طب
بندر بندر رف مصمم بندر اسطوري بندر
بندر اسطوري بسلا تشتغل
معه انا علي
بالمخرجات الله يسعده والله لكن
يعني فيعني نتفك ونوصل الى هذا اللون
ويقنع ويطلع شيء رائع
مذهل بد ما ادري ايش يصير يجي يمكن اجازه
اسبوع يوم الاحد ما عجبني نعيد من جديد
خذوا هذا هذا الشكل الجديد اللي انا
اكتشفته رائع فزي كذا فيعني بس تخليل على
النمط الداكن ان عندنا يمكن 40 نسخه 30
نسخه المشغل في 60 مليون نسخه طريقه
الفصول في 60 نسخه الصاله نفسها الصاله يا
الله يا الله يا الله طبعا يجي الحين يعني
في العمل مع ناس انا احب اشتغل مع ناس
عندهم راي بندر مثلا عنده راي حاد حاد حاد
اوكي ف يوصل انه يوصل الحين النقاش انه
اذا كان هو تصميم خلاص هو اللي ينتصر
فيقول خلاص انا اقول كذا نقفل النقاش او
انه قرار منتج قله خلاص انت اطلع منها انا
اقوللك كذا ممتاز ممتاز بس ان تخيل النقاش
كيف ياخذ
وانا هذا اكثر شيء عاجبني يعني لما
التطبيق تستخدمه واضح انه ناس استخدموه
فكروا فيه وسووا اشياء منطقيه ما سووه فقط
لانه جميل ولا لانه اللون رائع وهذا اللي
انا اكثر شيء من جذب لله صراحه موضوع
الاستخدام الاستخدام في رائع ممتاز في
ملاحظات واكيد شايفين كيف انه في احيانا
بطء لما اختار الاشياء اللي تتكرر يوميا
الواحد لكن هذه طبيعي يعني طبيعه الدوره
حق التطبيق كتجربه اولى رائعه جدا ما شاء
الله تك انه كان عندنا تحدي ثمانيه انه
يعني لو لو كنا شركه
ناشئه شركه ناشه لكن لو كنا اول شيء
سويناه في الحياه الناس عرفونه من خلال
التطبيق لكان خطا انك توصل لانك تنتجه
بهذا الشكل لكن لان ثمان الناس تتوقع منها
شيء يتوقعون يعني ما يبدك تطلق تجربه لسه
لم تنضج الى حد ما 100% ف جلسنا اشهر ولا
يعني ظهر انه كان جاهز من سنه انه يشتغل
بس انه اخذ سنه الثانيه في محاولات
التطوير بس كان لازم نحدد موعد ان نطلق
100% خصوصا انت ما انت جاي بشيء يعني
خليني اقول جديد كليا انت عندك منافسين
ومنافسين موجودين في السوق والناس متعودين
عليها فكيف بانفسهم هذول هذه الحالها يعني
تخلي الواحد لا انا ما بطلع بشيء انا ماني
مقتنع فيه
صراحه الحين بقوللك حاجه احس ابراهيم
بينحني هو
وانس احنا عندنا
مستهدف انه خلال السنه
هذه عندي يعني احس عشان ما الزمهم والله
بس انا احس ان هذا اللي يصير ان شاء الله
يا اخ مديركم حليل
ياي اخذ
دوره تقفل على
الناس لا بس الهدف ان شاء الله يعني احنا
عندنا اليوم ت نقرا البيانات اللي تجي على
ثمانيه فالناس اللي تسمع مع ثانيه من وين
يسمعون وكيف يسمعون فعندنا تقريبا اتوق
87% من الناس تسمع عن طريق هذا البودكاست
اوكي رقم مهول جدا بين يجي جوجل بودكاست
بعدين يجي مادري ايش بعدين يجي سبوتفاي
ظاهر يعني في الاخرى او شي زي ناس المهم
يجي كذا هذه التطبيقات فهذا الرسم
البياني هدف هدف ان ان
50% تتحول هذه الرسم البياني
من هذا الشكل الى ان 50% على راديو 8 50%
على كل التطبيقات الاخرى يعني انتم تبون
تطلعون جلوبال مو بس هنا لا لا سو احنا
ناخذها على المكتبه اللي عندنا هذا التحدي
لكن انا اتوقع ان في ناس في العالم
يستخدمونه لانه كون رائع حتى خصوصا كيف
احنا بنخلي الناس تربط يعني في مزايا
رائعه لان احنا
بودكاستر سبوت فاي ما هم بودكاستر ولا ابل
بودكاست مو بودكاست ولا المهم شركه
بودكاست ما يفهمون بودكاست
او ذراع بس موجود يعني هم يسوونه حلو
بالنسبه لهم و يضبط ضبط ضبط ما ضبط يعني
ما هو اخر همهم بس احنا نفهم مشاكلنا نعرف
ومشاكلنا ما هي مشاكل فريده فينا قدم ان
هذا اللي يعاني منه العالم كله فانا اتوقع
ان العالم يستخدمه يما ما عشان كده نبغ
نشتري راديو دوت كوم
ا اذا تلقى
رخيص مع نطاقات هذه والله عندنا احنا
نطاقات دي سالفه والله ترى بطل بطلوا
النطاقات
حرفيا عارفين شي ماله قيمه ابدا يعني يعني
هو بس
احيانا شيء نفسي شيء نفسي 100% اول كان
على قولتهم انه ريل ستيت انه الناس
يعرفونك بالنطاق هذا الحين انا اعتقد 99%
من ضغطي للروابط عن طريق مكان شفته وضغطت
عليه ارح اكتب اروح اكتب بسرعه اروح اكتب
يعني لو بدخل على ابشر اكتب ابشر في جوجل
خصوصا ما يحتاج انك تدخل جوجل يعني انت من
البحث حق فوق تكتب ابشر بديك على جوجل
بعدين تضغط الرابط تخيل ابشر هو ابش والله
مادري
شب واسعارها غاليه على يعني على قيمه صفر
قيمه مازالت غاليه انا مستخ لازالت غاليه
غاليه في اشياء الاربع حروف خمس حروف
الملاين له في ناس بزنس حرفيا يشترون 20
واحده ويقعدون ينتظرون زلان شاري
نصص ريال دت كوم ا 4 مليون دولار 5 مليون
دولار زي كذا ريال اي ريال دت كوم يلا مو
مشكله الحمد لله ان
الدراهم هل كنت بتسم ريالات هل كان هذا
التحدي عندك ولا دراهم من البدايه يعني من
البدايه ماه ما هو زي نقمه دراهم الاسم
الاول اللي بغينا نمشي فيه دائره الحمد
لله ان كمان اي وشز ما كان صراحه دراهم
كان علينا يعني اكثر شيء بس ترى لحين مو
دراهم دوت كوم دراهم دو ولا حتى رابط
دراهم نفس ولا يهم ولا يهم والله ما اعرف
لو تحط دراهم سلطان خيال ك اس اي هي بضغط
بوصل بس بس لا تضغط الرابط قبل ما تتاكد
منه
عشان
انتبه عاد طلعت علي
مقاطع استخدم عليك الذكاء الاصطناعي ما
شفتها انا وعمر جريسي في خونك تستثمر اذا
تبغى او يقولون اشوف الكونفرجن عليها كو
لا المشكله ان خايس والله يعني يقهرني يا
اخي ما يضبطونها احس لو انا بسويها بكتب
على الناس يا اخي بضبطها يا اخي بشكل
افضل علاقتنا
معال حطه على وجهك عشان ما يبان
مره على
دخل الوت غلط الصوت خطا بس احيانا يجيب
يمكن جزء من مقطع وجزء
حقيقي
هذا ما اتوقع ذكاء هذا ح واحد مركب صوت
على
وست والله يا اخي والله مشكله كبيره يا
اخي انا شفت مقطع مستر تحلها واضح يعني
كذا كان مره مره متقل ترى احيانا يعني
هذول يستهدف انه ما يكون ذكي انه يلعب
عليك مره لانه اللي اذا كان ذكي مره ولعب
على سلطان يعني بتدخل بتكتشف ان غلط وتطلع
على طول فيعني هما انت الغير مستهدف صح صح
ص هو يبغى واحد تمشي عليه اللعبه البايخه
هذه فاذا مش على ذي بتمشي عليه كل سلسله
الالعاب صح صح صح بودكاست احتيالي ما
يتفرج متى الموسم الثانيه قريبا كفو والله
قريبا ممتاز ممتاز حصريا على راجه ثمانيه
ترقب راع والله رائع جدا لا احت احتيار
رائع اتكلم عن هذه يعني هو كان يستهدفون
الناس اللي ما يفهموا في التقنيه كثير
لانهم خلاص بيكملون معك الاليه خلينا نقول
والعمليه اما لو جبت واحد فاهم يك ثاني
خطوه خلاص ودرب خلاص ما ما بس اي يعني على
طب يعرف انك كذاب يقفل فليش انا اضيع وقتي
معك خليني انا احط فلتر بان رساله
الاحتياليه ما هي ذكيه فاذا انت تجاوزت
الفلتر هذا ابد حياك اهلا بك ساسر والله
يا اخي والله مصيبه يعني مصيبه تحدي والله
تحدي وكثره كاثره مره يعني يعني مهما
الجاس يحاول البنك المركزي البنوك مادري
ايش يعني مثلا
الحين م الراجحي يعني صار لما توثق
العمليه ما فهم ترى الفكره خلفها بس في
الموثقه عاده يقوللك للتاكيد اضغط واحد
للرفض اضغط اثنين راج ايش يسوي كل مره
تصار راندم للتاكيد اضط سته بس ما فهمت
يعني في الاخير انا بسمع بس برضه تقدر انك
تعتمل الموضوع هذا تقدر انك تتمت انه
الواحد خلاص استقبل المكالمه على كمبيوتر
وصير على طول دايركت اضغط واحد جد لازم
تسم ال وترف الرقم وتط يعني هي ترى يعني
ملاحقه لن تنتهي ابدا كل ما هذا قوى هذا
بيصد وهذا بيقوى هذا بيصد فما ما بتنتهي
يعني بس خل نتفق انها ما هي عمليه سايبر
سكيورتي ما هي سيبرانيه هي يعني خداع
للناس هي اساسا خداع للناس فقط فناس
تقوللك او لا هكروني
لا لا هو هو لعب عليك بان يعني ايش
يسمونها هي هندسه اجتماعيه هندسه اجتماعيه
يسمونها فيعني هو انه عرف بعض المعلومات
عنك اللي
خلته خلته يحسسك انه هو من بنك ولا هو من
شركه اتصالات ولا من شركه استثمار ومن ثم
انت قدمت المعلومات اضافيه فصار يعرف
فيعني وهكذا هذا هو يعني بالخير الحلقه
الاضعف هو فمهما هذا صحيح هو دائما يقوللك
اصلا انه انت مات الانظمه بشكل عام
والاجراءات اللي موجوده هي ما هي عشان
تمنع الاختراق بالضروره بقدر مع انه اذا
الواحد اخترق انا احط عقبه قدامه فاخترق
بنكك وسوى العمليه اخر عقبه طيب التلفون
وبغير الرقم كمان فواحده منها بيطيح يعني
انتبهوا اي لا لا وال تحدي بس احيانا يخوف
ان لما يصير تصير مشكله كبيره انه يصير
تصحيح اعلى مما ينبغي فيصير كذا اوفر
كوركشن فهذا يعقد يعني يعقد تجربه الناس
كلها يعني انا اعاقب او ملايين يعاقبون
بسبب اخطاء
فتصير انا اول كنت احول على طول مع انا
وال احس اني مرتاح بس
القصد ظه الحين السي س ب ان العمليه اذا
فوق 200 ريال لازم يتصلون عليك او 250
ريال شي زي كذا يتصلون عليك يا كدون ان هل
تبغى تحولها من اميل يل فزي كذا تصير بدل
ما كنت اول كنت احول بسرعه صار اجبرنا على
انه يصير في اتصال في تاكيد في مدري ايش
فتصير عمليه المستخدم او تجربه المستخدم
اكثر تعقيده ظور اللي ما تم الاحتيال عليه
الحمد لله الى الان لكن من منظور اللي تم
الاحتيال عليه تبدا كذا تنقلب الايه ليش
كذا وكيف تسمحون ش هذا عرفت كيف ف يصير
يتفهم الاشياء هذه كف افهم انا واح الشباب
اقفل كل البطاقات من الشراء الالكتروني
تماما خلاص ما عاد اشتري اونلاين اي الصب
عليه بمبلغ 3 ال كذا فخلاص حرم الموضوع
هذا وقت عادي كلموني عش مرات يا رجل اتاكد
قب رجال روح سدد كاش
لا تحدي طيب شفت الموقع سلطان شفته بس ما
يعني ما سجلت جربتها يعني قاللك بنعطيك
اكسس اصلا يعني انا ماني كاتب
للاسف لازم نعلمك والله يا اخي الكتابه من
الاشياء اللي اتمنى اني اسويها بس ما طيب
بس ليش يمديك يمدي دراهم يصير على ثمانيه
صح دوتكم سدنا يعني مدونه عشان بس ايش
لناش تفع لنا تروح تف دقيقه انت لو تبغى
تسوي مدونه ايش بتسوي اخذ جوست اوب واسوي
انستول لا اوبن سورس واسوي انستول وخلاص
عندي طيب هوست الهوست كم ق عليه دافع دافع
هوستينج يعني ترافيك بسيط ما ب اي بس في
الاخير انت اللي تدفع يعني على اي ح او
انك تروح تاخذ يعني هذا وتروح تسوي للوك
وتسوي يعني لخبطه حقتها و عندك
مبرمجين فانت انك تفهم بتروح مع ذلك بتدفع
مبلغ بسيط بس انك يعني عندك موظفين لو
تحسب الكوست حقهم الليجا عشان يسوونه يمكن
ما تسو بس فانت انت اللي تدفع ليش يم عشان
ايش عشان خويك عشان سعودي ولا تدفع
لامريكي بس ما تدفع السعودي لا هي الفكره
انا لما اجي ثانيه ابى اجي لقيمه النشر
الموجود وقيمه المجتمع اللي موجود فانا
بعطيك ترى انت الناس تدخل على دراهم دو اس
اي يعني يمكن انت دراهم دو اس سلاش بلوج
مثلا فيدخل عليه موقعك ما يطلع يطلع شعارك
لوحدك ما يطلع شعاري خلاص تم فاهم المفروض
اقتنعت اذا تب لا لا واذا انت تبغى زياده
يعني قرا ترى يمديك تنظم شبكه مانيه
فمحتوى مشابه في هذه القيمه الرائعه اللي
انا لو بجي بجي عشانها ف مفترض انت ريالك
مو ب اللي اعطيك فلوس بس بعد ماجرب انت
الحين يقوللك كستمر اكوزيشن بعد ما
الكستمر ينب تب ترفع عليه الاسعار مشكله
بس قوللي قولي ش المزايا ما
تقولي تراهم خربت والله لا بروح حساب ستاك
واجي لهم بالله كم تدفعون لي عشان احط
مدون تدري تدفي تدري كل علد يجينا دراهم
بدون ما يدفع ولا شي احنا ندفع عليه تكلفه
كبيره جدا ندري بس اي طيب فه هذ كستمر
اكوزيشن كوست ما مشكله انا بقيت معك ايه
وكذا جزء كبير من الراتب يجس يروح عشان
القعده رائع جزء كبير اي تخيل معك اجيك
اجيك في مكتب كل في البيت عادي ماحتاج
فيعني في كلف الاستحواذ على ت بس بس يعني
هذا جزء من الموقع مثلا انه د هو صراحه
صراحه ودي اجربه لحماس التجربه في البدايه
وبعدين بالاخير دائما شيء زي كذا ما هو
اساسي في دراهم احنا دراهم مو الاساس
البلوك هو شيء ثانوي فاذا كان يبعد عن
الطريقه على قولتهم ويتيح لك انك تسوي
شغله بكل بساطه هذا الحاله كاف احنا
سويناه انه ما يحتاج ولا مبرمج ولا مصمم
يتدخل في الموضوع نهائيا انت كل كل موقع
او كل شركه اذا استخدم ثمانيه ا
يقدر يغير
تصميم عنده حاجه واحده يقدر يغير فيها
اللي هو اللون في لون اساسي في تصميم
الموقع القالب فتختار اللون حقكم البنفسجي
هذا فيصبح ابيض وبنفسجي بس لو تدخل على
ثمانيه تلقا ابيض واسود لو تدخل على اكس
تلقاه ابيض وما ادري برتقالي وهكذا فكل
منصه وبكذا يعطي طابع يعطي طابع شركتك
ولان في اللوجو فانت كذا ما تحتاج مصممين
انت بس تغير اللون حقه بس متاز واذا تبغى
تسوي بعدها تكتب تقدر تنشر نشره بريديه
فتقدر تسوي نشرات بريديه برضه بنفس الشي
تق طريقكم ترسل الاميلات
ولا ش الايميل اللي يرسل تقدر تخليه اد
دراهم او تقدر تخليه
ا بننا يعني محرك كامل
لرسل الايميلات الحالها هذه ترى يمكن تسو
عندنا لا واللي عندنا بعد يعني لان احنا
السؤال على الايميل جتكم مشاكل سبام وما
سبام انها ما توصل لا لا بقوللك الحين سو
اللي جايز نسويه الان احنا اول شي انه
عندنا نشرات بريديه لنا كم سنه ننشر نشرات
بريديه فعندنا تجربه حقيقيه مع نشات
بريديه واحنا نستخدم ملنب اولا سابقا يعني
فني ايش المصيبه يعني ترى ما يدعم عربي
يبغالك تشقلب احيانا واحيانا ممكن توصل
اسبام لان
طريقتهم
انه الاي بي الواحد يرسل 100000 شي زي كذا
رقم 100000 واحد على الاي بي الواحد فبكده
في عرضه انك تكون سبام كثيره لانه مو بس
انت اللي ترسل على نفس الاي بي فجوجل
وغيرهم يعملون هذا احنا خلينا كم 200 الف
صح الاي بي
فاقل اي اقل ففرص انها توصل اعلى بكثير من
ميل تشمب اللي هو يعتبر المعيار اثنين
وهذه كلفه اعلى علينا طبعا بس يعني نعتقد
ان تقدم تج بجيكم من مدخل يمكن هذا اللي
تقنعون فيه تقنعوني و تقنعون كل الشركات
المرخصه في السوق يعني هل هو هوستد في
السعوديه ولا
لا يعني نقدر نخلي هوست في السعوديه هذا
ترى حالها امازون اي امازون ح مضز ما فتح
السح قريب اول ما تفتح السع بس احنا اي شي
لازم يكون احنا عشان كذا ناخذ نظام ونحطها
عندنا في السيرفر في السعوديه عشان يصير
يقدر بسيطه هي ما هي بهذا بس ترى تكلفه
الاستضافه هنا اعلى بكثير من الاشياء
الانيه بسيطه يعني بسس بس هذه ترى اي يعني
حتى لكم للمستقبل لانه اتوقع كل الدوله
احنا ننتظر انه امازون بس تفتح احنا كنا
بنروح جوجل جوجل فتح و فتح بس ننتظر
امازون اذا فتح السعوديه هذه بتكون رائعه
جدا بسيطه بسي على موضوع الايميلات
الحالها ترى تسو تسو بشكل اي فانت تحتاج
انك ترس جرب وبرجعلك بكلم كذا ومو بس كذا
ترى انت لما تكتب الموضوع يمديك تخلي انه
نص يعني تقدر تقسم ش الاشياء اللي هذه
توصل في النشره بريديه وهذه بس تطلع على
الموقع كمقال لان في بعض الاقسام ما
تبغاها تطلع يعني زي يلا حي فلان او دعوات
خاصه ودي ارسلها بس تقدر تستخدم حت وتقدر
انت بيانات مستخدمين تقدر تسوي لهم اي هنا
عاد لما يكون مستخدم هنا ويكون فيه طبعا
لازم عشان برايفسي ما نقدر انه اي واحد بس
قصدي او الناس لما يجون يسجلون بس في
الاخير بيصيرون عندك تقدر تطلعهم اث ما
بغيت فلي نفرض انك بعد سنه زعلك علي قلت
والله
لاطلع تاخذهم تاخذ مقالاتك كلها تسوي لها
اكسبورت فتصدر كل شيء كل شيء و تطلع برا
وسلام علك تماما رائع فبيان انت تملكها
سواء كفرد ولا شركه يعني واللي شرحت الحين
للشركه هو نفسه للفرد يمدي الفرد يصير على
علي ابو صالح د ك الحين ابو مالح د كو
مالح ك بس النسخه القديمه
صح
بس ما جربت النسخه الجديده الى الان ولا
لا لا ما حولت الدومين حق حولين ح ف فكنت
اجرب يعني
حتى بس بس تقدر تشوف الافراد برضه وكذا
انت تتخيل ان عندك هذه كميه الافراد
والشركات اللي تستخدم نفس الشيء فاذا
انضموا برضه لشبكه الثمانيه اذا
يبغون وصول اعلى كذا كل احد صار عنده وصول
اعلى الكل ربحان احنا ثمانيه ربحان انت
ربحان الطرف الاخر
ربحان القارئ ربحان لانه صار يكتشف محتوى
يشبه لي هو مهتم له اكثر و بس ان احنا
نستهدف برضو الشركات اللي ما تسوي محتوى
التسويقي فاحنا نختارهم هو في الاخير
بيفيدكم ك تكلمون في شيء له علاقه بال عن
بالمال وكذا بس انه يجب انه محتوى حقيقي
محتوى ممتاز
ف المشكله الطيب انه الايميلات لما توصل
التنسيق حقها والكس تعبنا تعبنا كثير
عليها يعني بالاشهر قعدنا عشان نضبط هذه
الحالها يعني الاش تي ام ال حق الايميل
يعني غير غير في كمادات يعني رهيبه جدا
الاختبار الاملات ترى لقيناها حتى الخطط
العربيه ضبط كل شيء كل شيء لا لا سو افضل
تجربه ممكنه متحمس اغل ق ترفعون السقف
الحين عاد الواحد
يقولو لا
لا لان احنا
ترى يعني احنا اليوم ننشر واللي يستقبل
بريدنا يشوف انه مصمم بطريقه رائعه لن
نرضى ان يكون ان ننتقل الى منصه ثانيه
اللي هي الحنا في ثمانيه اقل من سابقتها
اذا ما كان افضل رائع فهذه هذا التحدي حك
والله يعني جربوا على قالت وانتظر اعلانه
في يمكن بس لازم يكون عندي بودكاست لازم
يكون عندي بودكاست ممكن ممكن يلا يمكن
ويمكن
لا يمكن ل لا ترى وارد انك تستخدمه كشركه
دراهم خلاص لما نطلع بس بعلمك اول ما نطفي
المكات اقوللك
عليها بس انها تجربه جديده بعتقد ان ما في
احد ما في تجربه عربيه لها مثيل
يعني فب بنسويها ا كيف طب انا هذه هذه
يمكن هذه النقطه الحين يعني صار عندكم
اكثر من منتج وكلها اثنتين منها لايف فكيف
خ نشوف علي ودي اسمع قص كيف ردود الفعل
بعد الاطلاق ردود الفعل واحد تغيير في
الاجراءات وال بروسس الداخليه لانه بطبيعه
الحال الرجنسي هذه والعجله انه اوه في
مشاكل في هذ صح صح صح صح اتفق 100 في معك
اول شيء وقت الاطلاق انا شخصيا ماتوقعت
السخم على الموقع بهذا القدر فالناس
متحمسين كثير على الموقع يعني زي التطبيق
اتوقع التطبيق بياخذ خلينا نقول جز الاكبر
لكن كثير كتاب جونا وقراء متحمسين مره على
الموقع فعلا اكثر من ما توقعت بمراحل يعني
مو طبيعي يعني اول يوم تر طح السيرفر
للدرجه هذه يعني اخر الليل فجاه كذا طاح
ربع ساعه يعني من كثر الناس كان متحمسين
الموقع يعني ف تفاجانا صراحه يعني ما شاء
الله ف فهذا بالنسبه للاطلاق الحمد لله
يعني ارقام جدا ممتازه يعني مستخدمين جدا
كثير جحين سواء في قام انتظار في التطبيق
او مشتركين في الموقع فحماس ل معان الفريق
كله متحمس طبعا ارقام ما ك نتخيلها لم تكن
في الخيال ما شاء الله تبارك الله والله
هو صراحه الاطلاق كان يعني يحمس يحمس 100%
النقطه اللي كيف انه الناس استقبالهم يوم
شافوا الواقع هل كان بحماس الهذا لا لا
صدق ترى انا كنت ا يخوفني لاني اقدر اشوف
مشاكل التطبيق يعني ترى قبل تدخل كنت انا
وعلي نحوش على مشاكل يعني فنشوف مشاكل
حقيقيه بس ان الناس يعني ردود فعلهم اعلى
رائعه رائعه يعني مثل ما انت شفته يعني
انك تشوف تقول يا اخي والله رائع نسخه ما
توقعتها يعني سواء من جوجل ولا من غيره
يعني اندرويد او اندر ل لا فعلا الفيدباك
مره دائما اصلا على المشاكل بعينك تكبر
كثير عن الشخص الجديد تبغى دائما يجرب
التحديث الاخير التحديث الاخير هذه اللي
فيها
المشاكل يقول يدر ش الفرق بين ذ وبين ذ
فعشان كذا دخل الناس بدون تحديث عجيب ان
الصاله استهلاكها عالي مره اكثر من تصور
اكث تصور الحين الصاله بس اللي اتابعهم
صح ما بت تخلون صاله عامه فوريو قصدك يعني
زي لك ترى لحالها ممكن تصير ممكن بس احنا
نبغ نضبطها الحين انه ما بينهم نبدا نضيف
اشياء يعني تساعد في التفاعل اكثر فكل
يعني فهذه من ضمن المزيل اللي ممكن
الاسبوع الجاي نطلقها صح ففي مزايا حلوه
بتضيف للصاله روح اكثر بس بس يعني ترى في
اشياء انت تبغاها فور يو تويتر سواها بعد
13 سنه اي لا لا عطني
اسبوع هذا اللي قاعد يقوللك عليه كل
يقوللك لا لاوم يقول زر يا رجال تحط زر و
فيديو تحط فيديو كا حط زرو بلايش فيك خمس
دقائق خمس
دقائق مشكله اللي مو تكنيكال يا مشكله انه
يفهم تكنيكال يعني لكن تعرف يمارس الضغط
هذا حقك نفسه يمارسه
علي لكن يعني اشرحلك يا سلطان وتتفق معي
خلي التسجيل ي
وال طبعا كان معتاد يعني خلينا نقول فرحه
الاطلاق جدا ممتازه والمستخدمين مره كثير
رهيبين يعني لكن لازال في اخطاء يعني ال
كراشز عندنا يعني في عدد لكن الحمد لله
يمكن نسبه الكراش في زرز يعني المستخدمين
ما اطلعهم اخطاء يمكن 97% يعني مره ممتاز
صراحه لا لا ممتاز جدا الحمد لله يعني
ف فبشكل عام نطلق ممتاز ش اللي قاعد نسويه
الحين وكيف الوضع يعني ف زي ما ذكرت يعني
بعد ما اطلقنا الشباب ك ارتاحوا يوم اليوم
اللي بعده فجاه الباك طلع مشاكل
فدر طل في مشاكل يعني على طول على قدق
مصلحها والحين يعني مخططين صح اح نطلق
احنا كل شهر لكن خلال الفتره القادمه بطلق
تحديث كل اسبوع بس عشان نقفل الاخطاء تطلع
الدوريه هذه ال نرجع لنمط الطبيعي اللي هو
نطلق عارف المشاكل هذه عاده ما تخلص
فدائما بتوازن ما بين المشاكل اللي حلها
والميزات الجديده اللي ابغى
اطلع تحدي صراحه تحدي مره كبير كيف توازن
بينهم خاصه على السكيل يعني انت ما شاء
الله جاب مستخدمين كثار لكن هذه نقمه بنفس
الوقت ام الحين اي مشكله صغيره صداها اكبر
بكثير من بس اللي نحاول حس اكبر مشاكل
نبغى نحلها هي المشاكل اللي ممكن لما
يستخدمه لانك انت الحين تنافس تطبيقات
ا مثلا في دراهم انا ما اقدر استخدم
التطبيق غير سعودي صح يس فتحدي ما بين
دراهم ملاءه وفير وفير اتوقع
ثلاثه فالتحدي ما بينكم انتم وانتم كلكم
بادين قريبين من بعض فاللي عنده هذا مشاكل
هذا عنده مشاكل
فما بس احنا المنافسه الان مع سبوتيفاي مع
ابل مع جوجل مع بوكت كاست فانت تنافس ناس
لهم عشرات السنين وتطبيقهم موجود وتطوير
مستمر سبوتي فاي فيها 8000
موظف 20 يعني فلا تقار والنقل مو سهله ترى
لما اني اعتمد تطبيق ماني سهل اني ارجع
للاول اذا هذا ما العكس فالتحدي هو كيف
انه لما يجي عنده توقعات على كيف تطبيقات
تشتغل لما يجيك هنا لو كان فيها مشكله
كبيره كريتيكال يعني ممكن ايش يسويه انه
يقول تدري انا ما ابغى استخدم ه التطبيق
ويحذف سهل انه يحذف عاد كيف ارجعه مره
مكلف مكلف انك ترجع من جديد فهذا اللي
يخوفني فعشان ك احس ان التحديثات هذه
الاسبوعيه اللي قررها علي لحل المشاكل هذه
انها تقلل نسبه ان واحد
يقول مشاكل تقنيه يعني احيانا اذا ما
اشتغل الصوت ولا اذا ما صار بالضابط او سو
كراش او ما قاعد يحمل او احس حساسيه
المستخدمين خصوص سبقات البودكاست بقات
المحتوى والسوشيال ميديا بشكل عام شبكات
التواصل الجماعيه عندهم حساسيه عاليه يعني
بسهوله تقدر تخسر م تسبيقات الاخرى يعني
البنك بتصبر عليه يعني تطبيقات البنوك
بصبر عليه صعب التغيير يبي تستهلك منه وقت
كبير مره
يعني قرض ماخذه منهب جدا انا ما تطبيق
البودكاست النقله اصعب بكثير من ن تر تج
تطبيقك انا ثمانيه كفو كفو كهو حبيبي
والله كنت اوفر كاست
فعلا صراحه الحين استخدم هذا شوي وهذا شوي
لان ما اعتاد على هذا شويه لكن نقلت سويت
الامبورد للمكتبه الثانيه ليش اقول صعب
جدا لانه تطبيق تعودت عليه وصار عندي اللي
يسمونها الماس ميموري اول ما هذا اروح
ابحث او في بعدين على طول ادخل على هذا
واخلص فاذا تعودت على شيء ب اتغاضى عن
مشاكل كثير صح الى حد معين بعدين تفقع معي
واقول اسمع لا ابو التطبيق واروح لواحد
ثاني فكسب بالعميل في البدايه هو الصعب
ترى ما هو انه تخسرون فهذه هذه لما يجرب
ويلاقي مشاكل مابي بينتظر بينتظر بينتظر
بيشوف شش اللي يحمسني عشان اجي وانا اعتقد
في كم ميزه رائعه جدا بتحمس الواحد انه
يجي فعشان كذا انا قاعد اقوللك الصاله كيف
انه الديسكفري حقها بيصير اعلى لانه اول
واحد يجي بدون متابعين ما احس بكيف انه
صار فيه تعليق انا دائما كثير اسمع يا اخي
بودكاست ودي اشوف الناس ايش علقوا عليه
فاليوتيوب كان يحل المشكله هذه لكن
بودكاست كثير ما اشوف ايش علقوا عليه
الناس بس دائرتي انا ما ادري مين اللي سمع
وما ادري وغالبا بيكون ناس قليله اذا كانت
عامه فانا ممكن اني اشوف شيء اكثر يعني بس
بشكل عام احس الدفعه الرهيبه اللي جت بعد
الاطلاق يعني عندنا الصاله وعندنا القوائم
يعني احس في ناس تحمس القوائم يعني اكثر
من حماستي لها بس انها رائعه صدق يعني
تجربه فريده انا لي فتره من يوم نستخدم
تطبيق يعني استمعت الى حلقات بودكاست
والله ما كنت باصل لها لولا اني اسمع عن
طريق راديو 8 لانه سلطان اقترح شيء يعني
لا الاله بتعرفه ولا بس لاني اثق في ذوقه
واحس عندنا اهتمامات مشتركه واقترح لانه
يعني فجاه انا حبيت حلقه جديده في بودكاست
جديد فهذا كسب
مستمع و انا كسبت محتوى جديد وهكذا يعني
اي لا لا الامانه يعني الصاله خلينا نقول
تطبيق راديو ثانيه ما هوق بودكاست فقط
يعني خلينا نقول ابل بودكاست جوجل بودكاست
اوفر كاست وغيرهم فقط بودكاست وحس تطبيق
يعني ما في مميزات اخرى يعني خلاص تبحث
تشترك تسمع بس لكن يعني الصاله والقوائم
انا مركز على الصاله اكثر الصاله الامانه
يعني كثير بودكاست اول مره اعرف عنها في
حياتي سواء من اذكر ثمود اكثر من حلقه منك
من حتى من ايمن يعني في حلقات ما اعرفها
ابدا يعني سمعتها يعني خصوصا انه خلاص انا
من حكر في دائره معينه يعني اشياء اعرفها
عن طريق غالبا تويتر شفت واحد غرد عنها
وكذا سمعت الحلقه واشترت برنامج غير كذا
ما قدرت اوصل لهذ البرامج ابدا يعني لا لا
لا الحمد لله حت قوائم انها تفتح لك اشياء
ما كنت تنتبه لها كذا موت جديد غريب تقول
بتشوفها بحس تجربه مثاليه اللهم لك الحمد
الله يقويكم والقادم افضل يعني لم نبدا
بعد يعني اول خطوه هذا لسه
لا لا يعني فاحنا نتخيل ترى المستقبل يعني
عندنا المقالات الصوتيه ممكن تضاف هي
تجربه صوتيه كامله ليس مجرد بودكاست
المقالات الصوتيه بعدين انك تجمع ما بين
المقالات والبودكاست اللي تتشابه مع
اهتماماتك
فتطلع بدي ممكن يعني احس ان المكتب
العربيه تفقد الكتب يعني كتب ما في كتب
عربيه في كم تجربه ل انهم يسوون كتب صوتيه
عربيه بس كلها ما كانت جيده
وبعضهم ما يقدر يستثمر كثير لان برضه مو
كل الناس بتروح للمنصه الجديده بس انت
عندك منصه فيها الان مئات الالاف من
مستمعين ان شاء الله تصير بالملايين يعني
قريب فهم يدي يسمعون وتجربتهم صوتيه ف ف
بقي كتاب فاذا جبنا الكتب وحطينا الكتب
الصوتيه احس ان تصير تجربه يعني مكتبه
فريده في التاريخ العربي جميل جميل جدا طب
كيف داخليا تغير ما تغير شي من ناحيه
تطوير الميزات البراي يعني اكيد كان عندكم
اولويات في البدايه فحين اكيد تشق الامان
الاولويات يعني كلها تركناها
الحين يعني حتى عبد الرحمن كان يكلم اسبوع
الماضي يعني قاللي كميه يضيفها يعني وقلت
له خلنا نشوف الجايه يمكن اضيفها يعني
كلمت امس اترت منه قلتله يعني انا اسف بس
والله رحت المهام رحت البورد حق المهام 57
مهمه الشباب قاعد يحلون الاسبوع هذا بس 5
يعني يمكن 70% منها اخطاء 30% منها اخطاء
ت المستخدم يعني اللون كان خطا النصوص خطا
هذا المطلع فوق هذا يعني ما هي خطا بس
انها خلي تجربه سي تحسينات يعني ف قلت له
يعني خلاص خلنا نوقف شوي بس يعني خلي نركز
على الاخطاء هذه نخلصها بعدين ننتقل الى
يعني اضافه ميزات يعني اضافه ميزات يبيلنا
نفكر ف بشكل اكبر الحين 100 لانه اثرها
صاير اكبر اول يعني كلنا بس 100 مستخدم
كان فتره تجريبيه الحين بالالاف الوضع
يخوف صار
شويين يعني متفائلين ان شاء الله حتى
الموقع نفس الشي ترى بعد يعني نفس نفس
الشي بس يعني الحمد لله الموقع ان ريان
شايل اي لا يعطيه العافيه ريان مو مقصر
صراحه كير ما شاء الله الله يقويكم يا رب
متحمسين وبس والله يعطيكم العافيه الله
يعافيك توفيق شكرا لكم شكرا لعبد الرحمن
عبود خلف الكاميرات وفي التسجيل الصوتي
والهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز المزي و في
اداره محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نوره
السبيعي وفي التحرير جميل عبد الاحد
والتلوين عبد المجيد العطاس ومنتج
البرنامج ايمن الحمادي هذا فنجان احد
منتجات شركه مانيه للنشر والتوزيع ننشر كل
الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع
المقبل
القاكم طبعا استاذ عنده سالفه هي الله
يعينكم جاوبوا يعني جاوب قولي يبغى يتعلم
تستخدم كم كل كم تستخدمون ت جي بي سي اه
انا بشكل شبه يومي الحين استخدم ما
تستخدمه ا يعني مره في الشهر احسنت الان
الشيخ يبغى يعرف
كيف كيف تستخدمه بشكل مثالي طبعا خل اعطيك
تجربه بسيطه اللي هي البر انجنير هذا
المقاط طيب تمام ليش ليشك ها لانه هي هنا
الزبده صادق خل بعطيك تجربه انا ل فتره
خلي نقول ما برمجت ما برمج مشروع كذا كامل
من الصفر يعني اروح يمكن اشارك مع شباب
تعديلات بسيطه في المنصات سوا في راديو
ولا في الموقع لكن ز مبرمج شي كذا كامل
جيد جاش السا 8 شباب كلهم مشغولين جدا
يعني الاطلاق وكذا ما في ل انا موجود فان
مسوي الساعه 8 الموقع عشان
كذا تمام شفت الامنيه اي شفتها صلحتها
عشان كده انا مسوي لحالي حرفيا
مز الاله
الذكيه فاللي صار انا ل تجارب بسيطه معه
بس قت خل اجرب مشروع كامل ما تج بيتي
ا اللي صار انه افضل طريقه انك تستخدم ب
تي كيف كنا نقول قب شوي العمل عن بعد انك
لازم تصير تكتب كل شي بالتفصيل نفس الشيء
عامله كانه موظف ما يفهم
جيد كل شيء بالتفصيل الممل اقول له الصفحه
الفلانيه فيها كذا وكذا وكذا وكذا المميزه
هذه الزر ابغى لون كذا و شكلك كذا وا وا
كذا ا اعطيتك المطلبات كت مستند يمكن كانك
3000 كلمه وصلت منك طويل يعني اسلي اياه
قاللي اوكي خلنا نمشي حبه حبه مع بعض هو
كذا قاللي جيد ممتاز قاللي ش تقنا
استخدمها قلت له واحد اين 3 وكذا بدا
اعطاني الفولدر ستركشر اول شي شرح لي كيف
اصلا اسوي كود قلت له انا غبي ما افهم قلت
له انا ما اعرف ولا شيء اعتب صفر قال لازم
تثبت المكتبه الفلانيه راح ثبتها قاللي
ماك لوندز اصلا قلت له ماك قاللي روح ثبت
المكتبه الفلانيه روح سوي زي كذا افتح
التيرم واكتب زي كذا فعلمني ا بدايه انا
اعرفها بسم
فهمت بعدها قاللي سوي فولدر زي كذا سمي
الملف زي كذا حبه حبه بعدين قال الملف
الاول اكتب فيه كذا اتاكد قاللي سوي تست
اكتب في التيرمنال ام بي ام ران ستارت
يشتغل و لا اذا اشتغل اوكي اذا ما اشتغل
قي خطا حرفيا كذا حبه حبه قعدت تقريبا
بالضبط بالضبط بالضبط عشان اسوي صفحه
كامله طبعا عشان تفهم السياق عشان الناس
تفهم السياق الصفحه هي عباره عن حدس
فعاليات ن حدس فعاليات كامل وفي لوجن
المستخدمين يقدرون يسجلون فعاليات ويربط
ببيس كام بنفس الفعاليات تمام اخذ مني
بالضبط 33 ساعه خلصته كامل ويك انين يعني
اخذ مني ك تشتغل في الويكند عليه ممتاز
جدا يعني ف لو انك استخدمت صح استخدمت شتا
موقع فه اسويت كامل لحالي فلو ماجبي طب مو
بالحالي في اشياء الامانه لو بسويها حالي
بتاخذ كثير وقت لاني لفتره ما برمشت بعض
الاشياء زي اللوج ان اوكيشن باي جوجل
الاشياء هذه فتره عنها فبتا اخذ مني وقت
خذت مني ع دقائق صار بديل جوجل ترى بكل
انا اشوف كثير من مبرمجين صاروا يستخدمونه
صراحه انه صار بدل ما يسال سؤال عاده في
جوجل وساك او فلو وياخذ الاجابه صار يصل
جيبي تي ويعطيه اجابه ميستا تعطيه الستاك
كامل لوك كامل يعطيك تفصيل كامل على طول
يعرف ترى الى الان يمكن هذه اكثر طريقه
استخدام الجي بي تي انا مقتنع فيها 100%
الطرق الثانيه مثلا المحتوى والهه جربته
سيء جدا صراحه طب عندي تجربه
ثانيه يا اخي عندي حساب
فردت عندي حساب انون ليش عندك حساب انونس
حساب والله لا حسابي حسابي والله حساب
انا حساب فردت عادي حساب فردت قلت بسوي
تجربه خل اب اسوي حسابي بورد باي جيب بيت
تي ان كل شي اكتبه بايج بيتي يعني ارد على
الناس واسوي موضيع
باي وال حرفيا بروكت عندك
ع لا لا رهيب قلت له انا مستخدم برو يوزر
في ريدت
واعتبرني يعني ابرد على الناس انا بعطيك
رسائل لناس وانت رد عليها تمام رحت معينه
حق الجيمين حق الكوره اول ما ينزل البوست
فيت انسخ واحطه فيي واقول ردلي وانسخ الرد
حطه جاني اب فوت في ثلاث ايام يمكن 200
فوت
موطبيعي في الناس يقول اوه جابات مر رهيبه
وردون علي وشكرا
النيك على الفكره يا جماعه اي واحد
متابعين هذه طريقه لا يعني لا اجاباتها
ممتازه ممتازه ممتازه يعني الناس مبسوطين
كانوا مره انا فخور فيك حبيبي الله
يعطيك وغيره يعني ترى في اشياء كثيره مره
يعني اسويها في الامانه اشياء مره مره غير
هذه يعني هذ تجارب خلينا نقول اذكرها لكن
في اشياء كثير استخدمها فيه مره مره كثير
في حاجه بنتكلم عنها بس بقولها في الاخير
كنا يعني هو عنده فلسفه في اداره الوقت اي
فكنا نقول تدري خلينا نسولف فيها يمكن
الناس تستفيد قال لي ايمن هذا الموضوع لا
تفتح
نهائيا علي لا يشبه البشر ما له علاقه ما
احد يبغى يسمعنا لانه لا
ي لانك بتتعب الناس نفسيا بس تحس انهم
مقصرين يحس انه ما قاعد يشتغلون وقتهم على
الفاض وهذا الطبيعي درت عنده اكسل شيت في
اسماء
اخويا اخر مره شافه و يبغى يشوف قلت
مستحيل الشباب كانوا يطقطقون عليه فتره من
فترات ويحطون الستيكر حق انتل انتل
انسايد عل مجود
الصوره ما شاء الله تبارك
الله لا والله فعلا فعلا يا ان طبيعي مهلك
الموضوع مهلك جدا الانسان يحتاج راحه
الانسان متفقين صح متفقين انا ما اتوقع ان
انسان مو انسان طبيعي هو ليس انسان بس
نكتشف الموضوع هذا الحمد لله الحمد لله
نقول الحمد لله انا مؤمن اني انسان يعني
صدق صدق يعني خل المتح علىك على جنب ما
يعطيك الشي هذا انكزايتي وتوتر وطول الوقت
الا لا والله الا والله
احس هو الحين شغل مود التعاطف مع البشر
اكت لا لا يا اخي يا اخي
متى يتعبني لما يا اخي انا اصنع بيئتي انا
ام بنظريه البيئه هذ انسك بيئه اشتغل فيها
جد يوم تغيرت بيئتي مكان لمكان اخر ا قلت
الرياض مثلا يخرب السيستم تماما ما اقدر
يعني انجيتي تنزل يعني دائما طبعا انا
عندي هدف اني الخطه اللي اسويها او اي شي
اقوله اذا جبت 80% فانا نجحت اكثر من 80%
ممتاز بس ما اطمح لله اقل من 8%
في تساؤل هنا فيي هدف حطه اي خطه اي كم
جيتك مادري ليش
واحد يعني
يعني يمكن هووس ما ادري صراحه
طبيعي انا امس كانت
70% حزين الموضوع
حبيبي لا والله فانا اسوي بيئتي خلاص زي
المكتب المكتب اللي فوق في المكتب هنا في
نفس المكتب في البيت بالضبط حتى نفس الشيء
يعني اللاب توب لازم يسار ما ينفع يكون
يمين خلاص اندمر زي كذا يعني ف هذا قاعد
ياثر عليك شخصيا اي مره ترى اي مره مره
يعني يعني مثلا انا مستحيل انام السرير في
مخدتين مخده واحده مخدتين ما اقدر انام
يعني كذا خلاص او خليني اطول في النومه
خلاص في اشياء خلاص صنعت البيئه خلاص سويت
هذا الشيء وخلاص اني اسويه جيد فاذا تغيرت
بيئتي هنا التحدي هنا اللي اتوتر رائع ما
شاء الله تبارك الله انا اعرف علي يعني
اعرف انه عاده في التطبيقات ما يهتم مو
يهتم بقدر ما انه ما تفرق معه الاشياء
اللي مثلا تزعجني وتزعج انه ا اللون هذا
تلاقي اصلا يستنكر كثير منها صح لكن في
العالم الحقيقي العكس تماما يا رجل فما
ادري كيف كيف صح ولا لا صح صح فعلا يهمني
مره الوقت يهمني الاشياء اللي اسويها والي
اقولها بالملي يعني بس رحت اليابان ما
تعبك يعني كمخت وقت عشان تخلق هذه البي
ثلا سبيع ثلا سبيع تقريبا وللان ترى ما
احس اني وصلت للمرحله المثاليه كم بالم
وصلت
يعني لا لا يعني 70%
% لا لا تحدي
والله يبغ ويك اوفر ويك كمل الزياده عشان
اختلاف
الوقت يا اخي مختلف مختلف الويكند هناك
مختلف الويكند مختلف فالاشياء اللي مفص في
الويكند هناك هنا اه لحد دوام الوقت
السعات قدام يعني لخبط الامانه مره فتبن
شوي الى ما احس وصلت للشكل مثالي فدائما
يعني خلاص اتنازل عن اشياء مثلا النوم
الاكل وقت الراحه فتنازل عن اشياء
اخرى هل انت حط هذه الاشياء في اكسل شي
يعني
اتح
طيبون لا لا طيب جيد جيد جيد جيد لا لا في
اكس شيت في اكس شيت وفي كالندر وفي مقالات
في كل شيء يعني في عندي لكل شيء حل في لكل
مشكله لكل تنظيم معين في حل الموجود يعني
واستخدمه بشكل معين وحتى الاشياء اللي
تخليني انسان يلا عشان تنبسطون لها حل
يعني
فاقدره كل شهر مراجعه للذات اراجع انا كيف
في علاقاتي مع الاشخاص كيف انا مع مع اهلي
مثلا مع ائتي كيف انا مع حتى الامور
الدينيه الامور خلاص اراجع نفسي بشكل شهري
اكتب رفلكت يعني كل فتره يعني فيعني عشان
عشان ما اصير مره روبوت ايش تسوي يعني
مثلا اكتب اكتب مقاله اكتب مقاله اكتب اي
اكتب 500 كلمه تقريبا لكل شيء اوكي اي وهل
عليها تتخذ قرارات ا اتخذ قرارات عليها
بعد شهر وممتاز مره الحركه صراحه فخلاص
بعد شهر ارجع اقرا كل السابق واتخذ عليه
قرار وهكذا طيب هل ربطت بذك الناعي هذه
كلها لا لا ايش بيخ
هو هوه يعني هذا البروت من جنير بس قاعد
يبني البرمت باقي ما
خلص لا لا التحدي والله يا اخي الفتره
الاخيره خففت يعني لي تقريبا ست شهور او
اربع شهور خففت خففت خففت تنظيم اي لان
خففت الاكسر شيتس عددها الامانه لان بدات
بدا التنظيم ياخذ اكثر من فايدته ايوه بدا
يتعبني اي ف خففته من كم الى كم نسبه ولا
عدد ت عدد عدد عدد يعني اول كان عندي يمكن
سبعه الحين صاروا ثلاثه اي الجداول اللي
اتابعها بشكل اسبوعي شهري ما وانت كدك
اثنتين صح
انا يعني مفترض انه على الاقل واحد مهام
التنظيميه يعني على الاقل يعني لا انا
شغال 24
ساعه لا بس تستخدم دوس تستخدم شي ولا ما
تستخدم ابدا لنفسك ولا ابل ريمايندر ولا
نوتس انا الاشياء اللي تايم سنستيف
ريمايندر يعني الشي اللي سوري مو تايم
سنستيف بقدر ما انه شي يحتاج اتذكر في وقت
معين وعادي اجله ريمايندر اشي ثانيه على
الكالندر خلاص يعني مواعي بس يا اخي مثلو
اسنان بتروح كالندر حط في التقويم مشه لا
بس يعني في اشياء طيب يا اخي بتكلم ابغى
احجز اني ابغى احجز موعد اسنان احط
ريمايندر احجز موعد جدد الاستماره جدد هذه
ريمايندر لكن خلاص انا عندي موعد وحطه
فيدر لا والله انا تدوس استخدمي كبير انا
تدوس مع كندر مع بعض تى فخلاص تدو تحط
فروم تو يطلع في الكالندر على طول كذا
بلوك فتلاقي البلوك حق مثلا النادي موجود
ك طول الشهر لا جربتها ما قدرت اللي يحط
النادي الصباح ما يا اخي هي عاده اذا
بنيتها بنيتها لو حطيتها في 20 كالندر ما
بت ممكن لا لا بس انا احطها لاني ابغ اعرف
متى بروح اي هذا هو فانا مضبطه عشان برضو
اني ما احط مكان بس يعني
بس ويعني استخدم ينز يعجبني يا اخي رائع
رائع رائع بس ما ير و تقويم استخدم
فانتاستيك فانتاستيك فما في ربط بينهم اه
فانتاستيك يربط
مع في بس ان هذاك يا اخي انيما
تسحب والله خلاص ممتاز ما ق شي انت ما
تفهم هذ اشياء حق
[ضحك]
البشر ممكن
احطها الشي اللي فعلا ياثر على انجيتي
الايميل سوبر هي
اسه بالاخير لازم تتخذ قر على كل ايميل
وهذ التاسك
الا مادخل ستخدم
ها يا اخي ها اذا على فلسفته بتمشي اذا
بتبغ تغير شوي تغير
مادك انا النوع اللي لازم اقرا رساله واحط
لها اركايف او د اذا خص سوبر يسو نفس
الطريقه ح شورت كت فشي قريته ابغى اسوي
عليه اكشن الحين سويت ما ابغى اسويه احطه
في اليوم ولازم اتخذ قر تر الاسبوع الجاي
الوقت الفلاني لازم اتخذ عليه قرار فيجين
هناك ويذكرني ان ترى لازم لا كثير يمدحون
حاولت حاولت ما حتى انا حاولت في انا كذا
احس حطني في الصندوق ما اقدر اطلع منه
فخلاص وترني انا اتوتر مره من ادوات كذا
يعني اطني الحريه كيف تنظم وقت الراحه يا
حتى وقت الراحه تى حطلع ما اكبر عليك
والله يا اخي الله اكبر عليك مسو لا يعني
وقت الراحه ل بلوك معين خلاص موجود يعني
لازم اعرف متى برتاح وكيف تستغله داخل
الوقت هذا ولاقت راح خلاص ارتاح ه اللي جا
سوي جووا يعني مخطط له
مسبقا ي الم صراحه بس كنتيجه شخص يعني
تعرف تشتغل معه بشكل ييك حبيبي حبيبي
حبي النتيجه رائعه صراحه مالك ما
يتاثر مشاعر الحمدلله